muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros aquí en france24 blanco
bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
donde partir de este momento y por las
próximas dos horas y media vamos a
llevarles todo el cubrimiento del tercer
día de la convención nacional demócrata
donde les transmitiremos los discursos y
hablaremos y también haremos un completo
análisis de la política estadounidense
con nuestros invitados y corresponsales
en la ciudad de nueva york y en la
capital de eeuu washington de zip
recordemos que este año debido a esta
pandemia de coronavirus la convención
del partido se realiza de manera virtual
por primera vez en la historia el día de
hoy se esperan los discursos de la
candidata a la vicepresidencia kamala
harris quien será por supuesto el plato
fuerte de esta noche también hablarán la
ex secretaria de estado y ex candidata
presidencial hillary clinton la senadora
y también ex candidata ex precandidata
presidencial dice bet warren y el ex
presidente barack obama entre otros
oradores
comenzamos entonces a entrar en materia
en ese tercer día de convención
demócrata en eeuu y para ello me quiero
comunicar en la ciudad de washington en
la capital de eeuu con nuestra
corresponsal diana castañeda diana muy
buena noche para usted la saludó
preguntándole entonces qué podemos
esperar este tercer día de convención y
cuáles serán sus platos fuertes además
de kamala harris y los temas que van a
tratar el día de hoy
hola buenas noches hay dos temas
importantes que serán centrales en este
penúltimo día de la convención demócrata
uno de ellos es la unidad vimos la
unidad de la nación porque el primer día
vimos que era la unidad del partido al
día de ayer el liderazgo o es la unidad
sobre todo de minorías y afroamericanos
y de inmigrantes y se va a abordar el
impacto que han tenido las políticas del
presidente donalson para estas en
minorías se espera por ejemplo que el
discurso de hillary clinton ex candidata
a la presidencia demócrata según lo ha
adelantado el partido básicamente aborde
un tema importante y es el de la
compasión y liderazgo del presidente don
al turno en donde ella asegurará que
muchos de los votantes le han preguntado
por qué no decidió cuando perdió las
elecciones tratar de volver a ejercer un
trabajo público también hablara
de cómo han sufrido sobre todo las
mujeres estos ataques del presidente de
donald trump en políticas que afectan
los derechos de reproducción al igual
que el acceso a la salud es para también
el discurso de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi al
igual que en la fórmula de vaivén kamala
harris quien será uno de los discursos
centrales pero veremos muchas figuras
inmigrantes que sobresalen del partido
demócrata por ejemplo uno de los temas
centrales y uno de los vídeos centrales
será de una joven latina indocumentada y
como las políticas del presidente de
donald trump han afectado a los
inmigrantes indocumentados en el país
también veremos por ejemplo a la ex
secretaria de trabajo hilda solís quien
hablará sobre cómo han impactado las
medidas del presidente de unalt son a la
clase trabajadora a la clase trabajadora
hispana y uno de los temas que también
se va a abordar al día de hoy es el
cambio climático así que sé
digamos una jornada extensa como lo
vimos el día de ayer también con
múltiples vídeos de ciudadanos mostrando
el impacto que ha tenido no solamente en
la pandemia sino también el impacto que
han tenido las políticas del presidente
de donald trump en el día a día de
muchos ciudadanos estadounidenses así es
diana como usted lo dijo entonces ahí
tenemos la carta principal de este
tercer día de convención demócrata en
eeuu y también por supuesto que se va a
tratar el tema de las armas en ese país
porque estamos ante el eterno debate del
control de armas en eeuu algo que él
preside el ex presidente barack obama
intentó cambiar pero que fracasó ante el
inmenso poder que tiene ese lobby
armamentístico en washington quiero
entonces para hablar sobre este tema
saludar a fernando godo analista
político ex vocero en español de la
campaña presidencial de cruise en el
estado de la florida y le quiero
preguntar cómo está el país en este
aspecto tras cuatro años casi cuatro
años de la presidencia de donald trump
bueno el país no está bien en estos
momentos pero eso no tiene que ver con
el presidente hay una epidemia de una
pandemia muy grande del corona vil que
ha afectado a la población en general no
ha afectado a gente en particular ha
afectado a todo el mundo y sobre todo
afectado la economía la economía estaba
en un repunte grandísimo que había una
gran creación de empleo habían mejorado
los empleos las tasas de empleo eran de
desempleo en la población hispana la
población negra eran las más bajas
y lo cual era bueno para todo el mundo
porque mientras más empleo a es menos
vamos a estar todos y todo eso se vio
afectado por el coronado y hermandad
ocurre una serie de regulaciones y han
expuesto incluso el cierre de muchísimos
negocios pero la crisis esta es una
crisis sanitaria una crisis de salud no
es una crisis económica es muy diferente
una crisis económica una crisis de salud
en cuanto a todos estos bases como los
motores de la economía están
perfectamente bien la economía se va a
recuperar rápidamente ahora si usted
tiene una crisis económica entonces si
me cuesta mucho trabajo recuperarse como
la que hubo aquí en 1929 de 33 por
ejemplo y muchas crisis que han que han
habido de tipo económico pero esta no es
una crisis de tipo económico y hay que
ver hasta dónde está la manipulación de
ciertos intereses
que hay para que esta crisis se agrave o
uno más o inflar un poco ciertas cifras
que se han dado casos de fraudes de todo
el mundo conoce nosotros descubriendo el
agua tibia
para hacer que aparentar la pierna como
una cosa mucho mucho mucho mayor de lo
que repito por supuesto que existe la
tiene pero una cosa es que si estaré
pidiendo y otra cosa es manipular los
datos de la información fuera de eso yo
confío en que el país se va a recuperar
y que todos debemos unirnos o sea no
importa si usted es republicano o
demócrata usted tiene que luchar o cosas
que mejoren a los eeuu de américa es una
gran nación y todo el mundo tiene que
unirse si usted toma ciertas posiciones
a partir de posiciones anti americanas o
anti eeuu no va por buen camino aquí hay
una constitución una declaración de
independencia que dejan muy claro lo que
es este país y en este país dice bien
claro que todos somos creados iguales
por lo tanto todos tenemos derecho a la
vida la libertad en la propiedad por ese
camino
mientras defendamos jesús
la gente de cualquier partido vamos a ir
bien ahora si es cualquier persona de
cualquier partido se pone a pagar eso
entonces no vamos a decir si son grupos
de personas
entonces el señor sí señor y con
respecto a lo que estábamos comentando
anteriormente el respecto a las armas en
eeuu al control de armas un tema tan
polémico en su país como como como está
eeuu
en estos en estos años donde ha estado
el presidente de donald trump a la
cabeza
eso es un tema muy interesante
el control de ama usualmente y ahí vamos
a hablar de los dos bandos los que se
hablan los demócratas cada vez que hay
una matanza culpan a las almas
normalmente quien comete las matanzas
son las personas o sea las ambas no
disparan sola yo le dio muchos artículos
e incluso de economistas famosos negro
negro usted dijo negro la palabra negra
por verlo besos para mí tienen un gran
prestigio como walter williams como
thomas sowell y ellos hablan de
blogueras y las almas los estados unidos
por ejemplo los años 50 aquí los
muchachos iban a las escuelas los
whitecaps
y en los días de su cumpleaños los
padres les regalaba nada más
era un regalo de cumple la tradición que
por ciento se tendió en las escuelas
tenía un plus de ama y otra no veía ese
tipo de violencia ni de comportamiento
ni esas patas sí entonces el problema
que tenemos un problema moral ahora
mismo un muchacho que mató a 14
adolescentes en una escuela hace dos
años más bien los oyes
le han hecho muchísimas manifestaciones
contra la sama yo no ha visto una sola
manifestación en la cárcel donde está
ese muchacho tiene la pena de muerte
porque es un criminal es un asesino mató
a doce adolescentes porque no hacen
manifestaciones está hablando de
estabilidad del caso
de parte la cndh es de estar hablando el
caso de paclín y el nombre que no lo
quiero ni decir del asesino porque esos
nombres no mencionan no vale la pena
eric mencionarlo es ese tipo de conducta
es la que yo quiero llamar la atención
sobre la gente cuando me venga a pedir a
mi punto donde ambas guías de toda la
vida ocurrieron toda la vida sea más 50
es de 60 años y que cuando mataban a
alguien la gente a la emprendida contra
el criminal
incluso activo linchamientos y quiero
aclarar que los linchamientos que
normalmente afectaron más a la población
negra porque es verdad en el sur eran se
cometían contra cualquier individuo
cualquier individuo que se metía un
crimen a veces los linchados blanco o
negro y entonces es porque la actitud
normal de la gente era el criminal ahora
no era no era la samba sistema oral
es que en ese caso todavía todavía no
hay sentencia sobre sobre nicolás
nicolás cruz la persona que realizó ese
tiro tape porque todavía no se ha
generado una sentencia contra esta
persona ese son rasgos de
interesantísima del sistema judicial
aquí desde ser tan blando
a veces se derrite es un criminal todo
el mundo lo vio cometer el crimen qué
cosa es lo que están esperando está en
estos momentos que se han filtrado fotos
a veces de vez en cuando haciendo
ejercicios ahí en la casa está fuerte y
los contribuyentes estamos pagando todo
eso ahora que hay con los 14 muchachos
incluso un muchacho de origen chivo que
luchó por salvar a sus compañeros ahí
tuvo la muerte a consecuencia eso que me
dijo hasta decirte eso que hay con ese
muchacho y con los otros muchachos que
en plena flor de la vida se vieron
truncada en la vida por eso sea hasta
donde vamos a esperar por la justicia
moza disculpando alarma que hay con el
asesino
gracias señor go por su intervención y
quiero saludar entonces a otra invitada
que nos va a acompañar durante estas dos
horas y media de especial en este tercer
día de la convención demócrata de eeuu
ella es míchel
manatt analista política estratega
demócrata y ex asesora del departamento
de estado de eeuu señora mana buena
noche gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 siguiendo ese tema
el tema del control de armas en eeuu y
hablando también de esa masacre en la
escuela de parkland donde murieron
creería yo también que fueron 17
personas en vez de en vez de 14 porque
precisamente también hoy se espera que
hable una sobreviviente de esta masacre
y le pregunto qué tanto evolucionado la
conciencia de los estadounidenses ante
esta problemática de las armas como lo
decía también el señor godó que las
armas existen pero es más bien problema
de las personas y no problema no
problema de las armas ya entramos como
como en esa polémica y cómo poder
resolver a lo mejor esta problemática
tan grande
muy buenas noches y gracias por la
invitación es un placer estar con qué
pena que interrumpa siempre na que
interrumpa está hablando precisamente la
ex representante de gabby giffords
demócrata por arizona escuchemos la y
vamos con usted inmediatamente vamos a
escucharla
un pie frente a una palabra y luego dije
otra mi recuperación
me ha hecho cada vez más fuerte banksy
ahora las palabras salen mucho más
fáciles para mí aún tengo problemas para
hablar pero quiero que mi voz se escuche
eeuu necesita que todos hablemos
incluso si tenemos que luchar para
encontrar las palabras
nosotros estamos en una doble vía
podemos dejar que esto continúe o
podemos actuar
podemos proteger a nuestras familias a
nuestro futuro podemos votar
podemos estar en el lado correcto de la
historia
debemos elegir a joe bailén winter y él
estuvo ahí para mi vida y él estará ahí
para ustedes también
únanse a nosotros en esta lucha voten
voten y voten
muchas gracias estábamos escuchando el
testimonio de gabby giffords ella en
enero de 2011 sobrevivió a un intento de
asesinato en el estado de arizona y
quiero volver entonces con a cenar con
la señora michelle manatt en la capital
estadounidense washington dice y también
quiero decirle a nuestros invitados que
a medida de estas dos horas y media
especial vamos a estar interrumpiendo a
medida de que también vayan hablando los
oradores que se esperan para esta noche
pero señora manatt usted tiene la
palabra en este momento entonces
continuamos con lo que le estaba
comentando que quedó pasado con esta
polémica en la red
de armas en eeuu y de que en esta curva
finalmente
una vez más muy buenas noches yo que
quiero contar con estos estas palabras
de la representante gabrielle giffords
que es un ejemplo en vivo de la los
problemas y el choque de política aquí
en eeuu
si eeuu no puede valorar a al ser humano
y a la vida de miles y miles de personas
de nuestros colegas ciudadanos
familias colegas estudiantes y
servidores públicos
no sé quiénes somos en este momento como
país las la representante gabrielle
giffords que está
han estado el índico esta zona un estado
un street profunda con la presencia de
españoles e hispanos en estados unidos
si no valoramos a la cita
qué pasó al me pertenece quiénes
somos hemos llegado a un momento
propicio y con gran gran posibilidad
para cambiar el estanque que existe en
eeuu en 2020 estamos ahora hace minutos
de la celebración de la democracia de
eeuu cuando vamos a nombrar y vamos a
escuchar las palabras de la senadora
kamala harris del estado de california
de donde yo soy
y ella va a aceptar el nombramiento del
partido demócrata y es un momento de
gran esperanza y posibilidades para el
futuro de eeuu y estados unidos como un
ejemplo en el mundo entonces creo que
estamos dentro de la realidad de una
pandemia ya
con cortado y 700 vidas
fallecidos hasta la fecha que ha creado
caos en nuestra economía en el sector de
estudiantes de familias de trabajadores
si no podemos tomar un momento de
reflexión de lo que está pasando en el
país y que necesitamos y aprovechamos de
posibilidades para mejorar el futuro no
sabemos dónde estamos debemos estar en
una posición de ver un futuro grande no
hablamos de una política de de algo
minúscula o de algo muy menor debemos
hablar y aspirar y aprovechar de un
futuro para todos y esto es el partido
demócrata y sin duda los televidentes
y todo el público que ha dado un momento
de enfoque sobre lo que está pasando con
la convención demócrata lo está viendo
que somos el partido de todos somos el
partido de la que el país moderno así es
señora más gracias función por su
intervención también quiero saludar en
este momento a nuestro auto invitado él
es patricio zamorano director de medios
hispanos desde el candidato presidencial
del partido verde y analista
internacional señor zamorano gracias por
su tiempo por acompañarnos aquí en este
especial de noticias de france 24 en 3er
día de la convención demócratas
siguiendo con el tema de las armas a los
jóvenes parecen estar tomando el relevo
en este debate y han creado un
movimiento que promete desterrar a los
políticos y que acepten el dinero del
lobby armamentístico como lo lograrían
así es ese es el tema fundamental yo
estoy un poco sorprendido con el
análisis que estamos haciendo porque
este país ha demostrado que ha fallado
en el tema de la justicia con respecto
al abuso de las armas no este país
estaba acostumbrado a tener masacres
cada año cada mes más arte traumática
como la de sant de grupos donde murieron
más de 20 niños en las vegas' formas de
50 muertos y una cantidad enorme de
ciudades que ya no podemos nombrar la
cantidad de masacres que ha habido en
los eeuu simplemente por la incapacidad
del país tanto de republicanos como
demócratas que son los partidos de
gobierno una incapacidad tremenda para
legislar de una manera efectiva y salvar
vidas yo creo que es una
irresponsabilidad enorme de la clase
política de este país especialmente en
el congreso que no ha podido aprobar
legislaciones inteligentes mesuradas
moderadas para controlar la libre
circulación de armas y todos los abusos
que han habido
y más antes no hay que recordar que las
armas que se han utilizado son de corte
militar son versiones civiles de armas
de grueso calibre especialmente la
famosa ar-15 un arma militar que se ha
usado en casi todas las masacres
contemporáneas esa arma debería estar
prohibida porque queremos armas
militares en manos de ex civiles
entonces efectivamente hay que hacer
esfuerzos reales cuando pasó lo de sandy
hook daba la sensación de que el país se
había traumatizado y que era el momento
de hacer algo es bajo el gobierno del
presidente obama no pasó absolutamente
nada no se hizo ninguna ningún
incremento de las condiciones de
seguridad de postulación de aprobación
para que las personas no todas puedan
acceder a este tipo de armas de alto
calibre de corte militar entonces yo te
diga que el país ha demostrado en el
tema que te estás preguntando el tema de
las armas una incapacidad tremenda y eso
es responsabilidad sin duda de las
instancias de poder partido demócrata
partido república
la casa blanca y el congreso que no han
podido legislar para salvar vidas de
estadounidenses y ahí entonces le contra
pregunto señor zamorano por qué vaivén
fue uno de los ponentes para una ley que
en 1994 prohibió el uso de armas de
asalto y dicha ley expiró en el año 2004
además baiden dice que es momento de
reactivar esa legislación de nuevo será
entonces un tema que dependerá de la
conformación de ambas cámaras en el
congreso
así es y tiene que ver también con lo
que tú mencionabas antes en la
introducción de este programa con
respecto al tema del lobby hay un lobby
enorme enorme de los fabricantes de
armas en los eeuu y muchos de los
políticos tanto del partido demócratas
como republicanos se deben a ese lobby
que les colabora con fondos no solamente
republicanos la asociación nacional del
rifle también le da dinero a demócratas
entonces hasta que no se transparente el
uso sucio del dinero también del dinero
de los contribuyentes para campañas
electorales que terminan básicamente con
una incapacidad legislativa y no poder
legislar y hacer leyes que salven vidas
entonces ahí hay un problema grave que
tiene que ver justamente con la
incapacidad como tú mencionabas los
candidatos actuales y anteriores nadie
ha podido romper el lobby de las armas
que es extremadamente poderoso y que no
acepta no acepta ningún tipo de
concesión justamente para salvar vidas
así el señor sea moral entonces quiero
volver nuevamente con el señor fernando
godo en la ciudad de miami en el estado
de la florida y también hacer una
recapitulación porque payden ha hecho
justamente un llamado a los más jóvenes
a las poblaciones de entre 10 y 80 y 5
años para que voten masivamente con este
tema de las armas en la mente cree que
ese discurso de bailén pueda llegar a
esa población joven como él quiere
todos los políticos tratan de llegar a
la población joven porque la población
joven generalmente no vota o se torna
más apática en este sentido hoy en día
no existe tanto eso en las universidades
donde siga en movimiento generalmente en
favor de posiciones más a la izquierda
porque hay muchos profesores
universitarios que tienen esas
tendencias de la y la educan en en sus
alumnos ahora el tema de las almas sigue
siendo controversial aquí se prohibieron
las armas automáticas de los tiempos de
la ley seca y cuando hubo todo ese
bagaje criminal en sobre todo en chicago
que costó muchísimas vidas ahí son
muchísimos millonarios vivir la
corrupción se llevó a escala es
impensable ahora es jugar no recordar
qué es una cifra que cuestionan el
problema que el problema sigue sin
entrar en debate sigue centrándose en
las armas y te lo digo porque chicago
durante muchísimos años estuvieron
prohibidos las almas después de eso y
era la ciudad en más riesgo criminal en
los eeuu ley el estado de illinois en
general pero sobre todo chicago y te vas
a un país como suiza donde prácticamente
es obligatorio que cada ciudadano tenga
un arma de tener el arma que le dé la
gana y es uno de los países con menos de
sus criminales en el mundo entero de
algo vemos el punto sé cuál es el
problema sigue siendo el arma o el
criminal yo te diría que el problema
está en la moral y está en la educación
o sea si sencillamente hay una tendencia
a la violencia en todas partes por un
video game con montones de cosas que
pondrán a los muchachos violentos de
jóvenes no tras la varita de los 14
muertos en paquete
de centraba sobre todo los adolescentes
puede ser muy triste eran 14
adolescentes que tenían menos de 15 años
u otras tres personas
en realidad murieron 17 personas y todas
las vidas son importantes por lo tanto
no demeritó que esas otras tres personas
hayan muerto que fueron profesores
etcétera pero pero cuando matan niños
prácticamente a flor de vida es un parte
de todo el mundo y el problema sino
diciendo si al otro día de los 45 días
al mes
nicolás cruz hubiera subido pasado
funcionado si eléctrica ha pasado por la
samba yo te aseguro a ti con un montón
de criminales en este país que ahora
mismo estuvieron pensando cometer este
tipo de delito no lo cometería pero qué
pasa se meten día 15 20 30 años en la
vez entonces la ley es muy blanda y hay
que ver hasta donde la ley se puede
implementar la ley sobre todo para
castigar al cristiano
bueno ahora estaba pidiendo la palabra
la señora maná señora maná volvemos con
usted a la ciudad de washington y ya
también para cerrar este tema de las
armas y meternos con el tema de la
energía el cambio climático que es
actualmente lo que están discutiendo en
la convención demócrata la señora mana
te escucho
esta está manejando dos temas a la vez
que felicitó quiero llevarnos todos
cuatro años atrás a junio de 2016 cuando
el 12 de junio
hubo un ataque masivo en un lugar de
recreo un lugar importante de noche
cloud que se llama post night live donde
en orlando en florida una ciudad que
apreciamos todos nosotros en esta en
este programa en el en el corazón de
florida que pasó en el club dos murieron
fallecieron varias personas jóvenes
sobre todo porque por una ataque de una
persona que una de estas armas ak-47 que
ha mencionado el otro colega antes por
qué pasó esto por falta de
gris nivel y saint jean alesi en nuestro
país que pasó diez días después en la
cámara de representantes que pasó hubo
un set en una toma del piso una toma de
la de la cámara de representantes por
quien por el representante john lewis
jones
de jeans y la mayoría en la cámara baja
para decir ni una vida más y propia y
querían avanzar con la legislación para
ajustar y poner un poco de orden en las
leyes de soul news frente a ese tema
hubo un apoyo masivo del público de eeuu
que pasó después con días unos días
después llegó la del proyecto de ley la
de legislación al senado al senado de
eeuu en control de quien de quien este
mismo canal él el líder del senado y el
freno frenó la legislación porque porque
está incluido azul por la por la nba eso
es la realidad el impacto de ciertos
lobbies en nuestro país es demasiado y
es peligroso es un 1 es algo más que un
peligro es un freno masivo al progreso
para nuestra nuestra ciudad ciudades
comunidades y ciudadanos
no quiero ir ahora entonces con el señor
zamora no gracias señora michelle por su
intervención ahora quiero ir con el
señor zamora no metiéndonos más el tema
de la energía porque vaya promete una
inversión de 2 billones de dólares para
poner al país en un cambio hacia las
emisiones cero netas para el año 2050 le
pregunto si es realizable este plan en
un país como eeuu señor zamora no
bueno no es nuevamente todo eso va a
depender del fuerte lobby del petróleo
el lobby del petróleo es el que ha
frenado muchas de las muchas de las
medidas que incluso obama había avanzado
de manera efectiva obama yo diría que
era uno de los presidentes junto con
carteras se hace bastantes años que
había iniciado también una política de
expansión en una política ambiental de
medidas concretas de intentar
incrementar los recursos renovables
eólicos solar eléctrico en el caso de
donald trump
es bastante claro él lo ha dicho de
manera bastante clara es su programa y
limitar las regulaciones ambientales
porque los republicanos consideran que
muchas de estas regulaciones que
nuevamente salvan al planeta salvan a la
biosfera
que estas regulaciones ambientales van a
ir en contra de la iniciativa privada en
contra del desarrollo y donald trump ha
sido muy muy claro y efectivo en lo que
está haciendo ha sacado de los eeuu de
los grandes acuerdos ambientales del
mundo y ha retrotraído muchas de las
leyes que había aprobado obama para por
ejemplo controlar el uso del carbón e
incorporar un poco las emisiones que
eeuu es uno de los que apoya más a este
proceso de cambio climático y de que el
hecho de que el planeta se está
calentando más y más cada día no
entonces el propio donald ioam es un
escéptico de muchos de los datos
científicos que hablan sobre la
influencia directa del hombre de lo que
hemos hecho en estas últimas décadas
contra el clima y los republicanos en
general se han negado a aceptar esta
evidencia científica con un criterio
político para evitar que haya
restricciones a la iniciativa privada
entonces hay mucho que hacer que yo te
diría que donde le ha hecho un daño
tremendo al país ha aumentado el proceso
de fracking por ejemplo que es
extremadamente contaminante para sacar
extraer más petróleo y más gas y
fracturando a la tierra a niveles
profundos
a red realmente ha condicionado la
posibilidad de que el estadounidense
promedio tenga una vida mejor una
calidad de aire mejor una calidad de
agua mejor entonces yo diría que donar
que aparece controlar el contra la
corriente de lo que es este apoyo para
medidas ambientales y frenar el
calentamiento global que como tú sabes
lo estamos viendo está afectando mucho
mucho más a la población pobre de los
eeuu son quiero ir ahora con el señor
godo que es republicano porque
precisamente los republicanos acusan a
bailén de haber adoptado el llamado
green útil que es esta propuesta en
materia climática del ala más
progresista del partido demócrata y le
pregunta
que genera tanta polémica está propuesta
demócrata para una transición rápida en
materia energética señor godo
mira el cambio climático es un tema muy
polémico ese asunto de que hay evidencia
científica
y hay un montón de científicos en estos
momentos ahora mismo que han denunciado
que no creen en el cambio climático o
sea que alguien me diga a mí que viven
evidencias sustanciales hacia un lado no
es faltar a la realidad hay un montón de
científicos e incluso fundadores de
greenpeace y organizaciones de estas
fuentes que hablan de que eso no no es
una cosa probada negociada que la acción
del hombre sobre los gases de efecto
invernadero la acción del hombre de la
acción industrial del hombre provoque
eso cuando el co2 es un gas de ínfimo en
la cantidad que queda en la mujer vapor
de agua el gas de efecto invernadero
mayor en una proporción enorme enorme
enormemente superior buscan los libros
para que lo vean y que el hombre con
deseos de causante del calentamiento
duro al calentamiento que también es que
es cuestionable hablan de calentamiento
global la tierra se caliente se enfría
por cambios normales en el clima si te
vas a inglaterra en el siglo 14
el hombre florecieron viñedos de acá lo
que hubo en cuanta industria y cuánta
gente había de aquí en aquel momento del
siglo 14.000 allá era para decirle que
el hombre fue el causante de ese
calentamiento por supuesto tiempo
después de nuevo enfriamiento aquí en
los años 60 si coges cualquier periódico
cualquiera que se estaba hablando de una
era de hielo de lo que se está enfriando
la tierra incluso habían lo que llamamos
ahora meme de gente en verano con capa
de invierno del frío que había y
precisamente en los años 60 se había
producido el boom industrial después de
la segunda guerra mundial cuando se vio
afectada la producción industrial por la
guerra y precisamente después de 1945
empezó todo el segundo industrial de
todas las industrias empezó todo el
mundo a producir
y entonces el efecto que eso tuvo fue
que la tierra se comenzará a enfriar o
sea por totalmente expuesto de lo que
dicen estos estos en made
pseudocientífico que te están diciendo
ahora que la acción del hombre es la que
provoca el calentamiento de uruguay y
después de eso la tierra se calentó en
otro periodo pero si miras a gente de
tiempo que te estoy hablando del 1960
hasta el 2020 vas a ver que la tierra se
volvió enfriar entonces hay que hay
aires hay ciclos en el calentamiento y
enfriamiento de la tierra en los últimos
100 años e incluso que desmienten que
pueda haber sido la acción del hombre la
otra cosa que me da muchas gracias por
esta discurso el calentamiento global
viene de la izquierda que el origen de
cambio climático de ese problema de
cambio climático y que muchos de la
gente que hablan no lo sabe y fue
margaret thatcher que es una bien bien
bien mujer de derecha y ella fue la que
escogió ahí algo que ya estaba y quería
desarrollar la energía atómica
conducción
y estaba teniendo problemas con los
obreros hacían huelga en el campo
tenemos una serie de lo que ustedes me
atuve que el carbón afecta al medio
ambiente y entonces le hicieron la
guerra a los indicados del cargo
para eso se haber pero al final no era
una una pseudociencia o sea esos
científicos hicieron lo que ella quería
y cuando seca del campo socialista en el
año 89 90 entonces la izquierda se
aprobe se apodera de esta bandera del
cambio priman y ahora no están mediando
en todo eso y el objetivo es el control
del gobierno subiste los impuestos para
poner más regulaciones por supuesto que
hay que proteger el medio ambiente para
lo que me estaba moviendo y encienden el
como digo yo apaga un poco el cerebro
hay que proteger el medio ambiente
o sea eso no hay nada menos luz pero de
que el hombre tenga una incidencia en el
cambio climático y el calentamiento
global por favor
señor go sí gracias por su opinión
quiero ir ahora con la señora la señora
michelle man at ella está en la ciudad
de washington en la capital
estadounidense perdón antes de ir con la
señora manás vamos a ir con los
testimonios en vivo del tema migratorio
que también están tocando en este tercer
día de convención demócrata escuchemos
un poco de lo que está ocurriendo en
esta convención
pero todos merecemos una calificación
buena vida y salud me rompe el corazón
ver como separan a niños de sus familias
en la frontera eso está mal esos bebés
necesitan a sus padres en pixar access y
cherel sangre el corazón y ven a los
niños separados de sus familias en la
frontera de sus niños les afecta a los
padres yo voy a votar este noviembre por
mi hermana y mi familia quiero un futuro
en el que nuestras vidas tengan dignidad
y respeto necesitamos a un líder que
bing también se arregle nuestro sistema
migratorio
voy a votar córdoba y técnicamente hija
de emigrantes votar bien la palabra
únete
0 3 3 0
es una familia de emigrantes diciendo
que van a votar por el joe biden y
kamala harris estaba escuchando antes
también lo que estaba ocurriendo en esta
convención una niña que le mandó una
carta al presidente de donald trump dijo
que su madre indocumentada y acusa al
presidente de haber destruido a la
familia entonces ya si entramos de lleno
en este tema migratorio también con los
llamados dreamers quiero ir ahora sí
entonces con la señora maná tenacidad de
washington
y decirle qué va a pasar con estos
llamados gamers y porque el presidente
donald trump se ha mostrado muy duro con
estas políticas migratorias hasta hace
hacia esta población que son alrededor
de 700.000 jóvenes en este estatus de
protección especial
que son llamados dreamers soñadores en
español y porque en otras también se
muestra un poco débil o blando en esas
políticas contra contra este grupo
bueno el tema de inmediación la
situación de jóvenes nacidos aquí en
nuestro magnífico país que han intentado
y dedicado sus vidas como estudiantes y
como futuros votantes es algo primordial
en el en el año 2020 y la situación del
otro la situación de una persona un poco
distinto a cómo se ve el ser el señor y
ahora presidente de trump y su familia
es algo que ha sido una cosa fundamental
de su identidad como como carácter
político en toda la historia de los
últimos 33 años y medio es una tragedia
la verdad porque porque nuestro
magnífico país es a base de es fruto de
inmigrantes
todos sabemos esto todos los que estamos
aquí la verdad si no somos hispanos
de origen indígena somos inmigrantes yo
soy producto de inmigrantes tanto los
dos colegas en el programa son
inmigrantes
así que fundamental y primordial y es el
residente atrás
y su administración ha tenido una
estabilidad y una rabia frente desde sus
primeros días es una política central en
todo lo que han hecho tanto como el la
prohibición frente a la comunidad
musulmana en enero y febrero de 2017 así
que es un tema sin resolver vimos anoche
en la convención en en todo el programa
de la convención
un vídeo acerca de la vida de el senador
john mccain y el senador john mccain
quien falleció hace unos años atrás dos
años atrás el de donde fue él fue del
estado de arizona un estado de frontera
frontera con méxico el senador martín
fue parte del grupo que quería ver
un resultado de las del estatus de mucha
gente aquí en eeuu que fueron o o
nacidos aquí o traídos aquí en búsqueda
de algo mejor para su vida querían y
todavía tienen algo muy claro que tienen
intención de funcionar y de trabajar y
de respetar
en las leyes con cumplimiento de todos
los leyes
perdón las leyes todo el sistema de
impuestos aquí y en la administración
antes de obama fue a hubo un freno hubo
un choque de los dos partidos que que
fue imposible
para volver o para para para cumplir con
nueva legislación migratoria y sí que
fue esto la verdad es porque en en el
partido republicano hay tendencias de
división
es de poner un nombre del otro un nombre
de exclusión si a gente que no se ve
como yo yo soy fruta fruta de varias
personas y generaciones de inmigrantes
así que es un tema que ha seguido y
seguido y seguido elección tras elección
selección y es un tema uno de los temas
más importantes para los votantes en
2020 yo creo que hay con la expresión de
este vídeo estas tres mujeres que
vivimos mujeres sencillas mujeres
verdaderamente
con con un futuro en donde construir y
seguir construyendo al país ellas
quieren regular regularizar su estatus
así es lo que queremos todos sí señora
maná me quedo en la misma ciudad donde
usted en washington dc para hablar un
poco con nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda y que nos explicó un poco
odian a estas políticas de línea dura
contra la inmigración y contra los
extranjeros en eeuu
diana
así es desde que el presidente de unalt
llegó a la casa blanca inició digamos
una serie de políticas de cero
tolerancia para los inmigrantes en los
eeuu sobre todo inmigrantes
indocumentados su objetivo principal era
frenar el cruce de inmigrantes
indocumentados sobre todo por la
frontera sur con méxico y vimos cómo
empezó con el 'bund' migratorio a países
inmigrantes de países que consideraba
podrían tener células terroristas esto
posteriormente quedó sin piso debido a
las cortes y demandas que se llevaron a
cortes menores pero uno de los temas que
más encendió las alarmas durante esta
administración del presidente de donald
trump fueron las imágenes de los niños
en jaulas de los niños detenidos en
centros en la frontera sur y que fueron
separados de sus padres más de 26 mil
pequeños han sido separados de sus
padres y esto generó reclamos sobre todo
frente al tema de derechos humanos del
presidente pero
a esto se le suma también que ha hecho
una gran cantidad de medidas para tratar
de cancelar visas veíamos recientemente
de estudiantes extranjeros también de
cancelar visas para inmigrantes
calificados y uno de los temas centrales
a echar atrás este beneficio para
jóvenes indocumentados que es daca y que
ha sido frenado por las cortes entonces
hemos visto como durante su
administración el presidente de donald
trump ha iniciado estas medidas de
inmigración que son demandadas por
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos de los inmigrantes en las
cortes y esa ha sido la dinámica pero
además de eso no pudo conseguir al
interior del congreso de los eeuu el
presupuesto suficiente en dos ocasiones
para construir el muro migratorio el
muro para detener la inmigración que
prometió en la frontera con méxico ahora
bien estos testimonios que veíamos hacen
parte no sólo de 12 más de 12 millones
de familias indocumentadas que viven en
el país pero también hay algo muy cierto
que se ve y ahí está
familias mixtas es decir padres
indocumentados pero jóvenes que son
ciudadanos estadounidenses y eso será
central para los votos el voto latino
que veremos en estas elecciones y por
eso veíamos también al ex presidente
barack obama en este vídeo que salió
hace pocos minutos hablando de cómo eeuu
es una nación de inmigrantes y por eso
también vemos en esta convención
testimonios en español y uno de los
cantantes digamos más representativos de
la comunidad hispana estaba cantando
bachata en este tercer día de la
convención demócrata así es llana y
también estamos viendo entonces la
importancia de la mujer la importancia
del voto femenino en eeuu y de eso
quiero hablar entonces con nuestra
corresponsal también que nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de nueva york mamen sala
mamen hablemos un poco entonces de la
importancia del voto femenino en eeuu
además con cámara sabes la primera mujer
afroamericana en ser nominada a un cargo
tan importante como es la
vicepresidencia
de eeuu mamen estoy contigo
si además raúl justo cuando se cumplen
100 años y un día desde que las mujeres
pueden votar en este país así que qué
mejor ocasión para celebrar esta
convención y dedicársela dedicar una
parte de esta convención a las mujeres
vamos a ver diferentes discursos que van
a defender el papel de la mujer vamos a
tener a la presidenta de la cámara de
representante la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi
que va a ofrecer un discurso pues
atacando la actitud de donald trama
hacia las mujeres ella asegura que la
conoce de primera mano y pues bueno va a
lanzar un discurso bastante atacante
sobre como donald trump en estos años
que ha estado en la presidencia ha
tenido un trato hacia las mujeres muchas
veces pues no tan no tan educado como
debería no vamos a escuchar también a
otra ex candidata ex primera dama
hillary clinton que también además de
hacer defensa del poder y del lugar de
la mujer en este momento también va a
pedir el voto en un momento que es
sumamente importante que
todos los ciudadanos vayan a las urnas
vamos a escuchar también a la ex
candidata elizabeth warren que también
hizo una gran defensa del papel de la
mujer durante esas primarias que pudimos
ver en los meses anteriores así que va a
ser una convención en una un tercer día
de convención en el que una vez más
vamos a ver un importante papel de las
mujeres estos dos días lo vimos también
de las mujeres jóvenes y ahora vamos a
tener un poco de viejas glorias del
partido que nos van a lo que van a
defender un poquito nuestros derechos en
una jornada tan especial como te decía
cuando se cumplen 100 años y un día que
las mujeres pueden votar en este país
así es maman entonces ahora vamos en
directo con lo que está ocurriendo en
esta convención con la excandidata gira
de clinton escuchemos
la mente abierta y quería
quería una economía fuerte
para manejar una pandemia si los
demócratas estamos en desacuerdo con él
en muchas cosas pero si hubiera puesto
su ego a mi lado viendo la humanidad en
un niño que está en la frontera o un
manifestante que está llamando a la
justicia o una familia que ha sido
destruida por un desastre naturales
hubiera sido algo muy bueno para estados
unidos y para el mundo donde aún pronto
hubiera sabido que usar un presidente
porque eeuu necesita un presidente ahora
en este momento de crisis los
estadounidenses siguen buscando a los
primeros en responder en las emergencias
en los centros de cuidado porque aún así
se necesita un pueblo y en este momento
de sacrificio y el servicio necesitamos
a joe biden y todos tienen una historia
sobre como yo tiene empatía
recuerdo cuando como él no me llamó
cuando mi madre llamó me murió el mejor
testamento para young fue como
como cuidó de su familia y la doctora
que podrá seguir enseñando esto como
primera dama y yo escogió una persona
maravillosa en cámara alguien que va a
buscar la equidad a quien amable cuando
su secretaria estaba muriendo de cáncer
estuvo ahí todo el tiempo en sus
momentos finales y se me algo de los dos
las luchas que está pasando que pasó
cámara como soy skyteam así que este es
el equipo que va a llevar a nuestra
nación a la arriba de nuevo pero no
pueden hacerlo sin nosotros durante
cuatro años la gente me ha dicho yo me
di cuenta de cuán peligroso era el
desearía poder hacerlo de nuevo debía
haber votado miren es que ésta no puede
ser una elección debió haber sido podría
haber sido si votan por correo
míralo ahora y háganlo inmediatamente si
lo hacen en persona háganlo
para no mouse lleven a un compañero usen
una máscara no importa lo que pase botón
como nos dijeron michelle obama y bernie
sanders si trump es reelegido de las
cosas van a empeorar y por eso
necesitamos unidad ahora más que nunca
recuerden en 2016 cuando trump dijo que
tienen que perder bueno ahora sabemos
nuestro cuidado de salud nuestros
empleos a nuestros seres queridos
nuestro liderazgo en el mundo incluso
nuestro sistema postal
pero aún más allá de sacar a un hombre
de la casa blanca- joe biden y kamala
harris nos van a dar mucho más para
votar
podemos por los trabajos que yo va a
crear
la energía limpia un salario justo
ayudas para los pequeños negocios que
salven a las personas de ser evacuados
de sus hogares no es justo que los
millonarios se hayan hecho mucho más
ricos durante la pandemia mientras que
muchos han perdido lo que ganaban con su
empleo extra los padres y los profesores
que están luchando para mantener a sus
hijos educados con seguridad y para los
trabajadores de la salud sin ayuda de la
casa blanca o muy poca ayuda para luchar
contra la pandemia
wang por su seguridad médica para todos
una paternidad planeada para todas
nuestras familias para las fuerzas de la
ley y para una equidad racial que
mantenga en nuestras calles
seguras gluten por voten por la justicia
porque las vidas negras importante voten
por una elección honesta para correcta
nosotros no una persona extranjera elija
a nuestro cliente a nuestro presidente
voten por eeuu
como lo vimos en la noche de anoche yo y
cámara pueden ganar por incluso tres
millones de votos y aún así perder
tómenlo de mí pueden los números ser
abrumadores pero 8 puede robar la
victoria
si bien la palabra vote al 30 30 hace
100 años ayer la enmienda número 19 fue
certificada tomó décadas de personas
siendo la cárcel y marchando para que
llegáramos a un estado mucho más
buscando
y su trabajo no estaba listo aún pero
hoy estoy pensando en las mujeres y los
niños que se ven en el futuro de estado
unidos gracias a una mujer
hija de inmigrantes y nuestra candidata
este es la historia de nuestro país
derribando barreras y expandiendo el
círculo de las posibilidades y para los
jóvenes viendo no se rindan en eeuu a
pesar de nuestras fallas y problemas
hemos llegado muy lejos y podemos ser un
país mucho más justo y equitativo las
generaciones pasadas nunca pudieron
imaginar esto es mary la verdad es que
muchas cosas estaban aún dañadas previo
a la pandemia
y después de esto algunos de nosotros
vamos a ser más fuertes en ciencia él
sabe cómo continuar como unirnos como
liderar porque lo ha hecho para su
familia y para sus fans así que en
noviembre si somos fuertes juntos vamos
a sanar whiting vamos a
volver a tomar la promesa de nuestros
países liderados por el presidente joe
biden y la vicepresidenta kamala harris
y entonces estaban viendo la ex
candidata presidencial demócrata también
ex secretaria de estado hillary clinton
hablando entonces un poco de la
importancia del voto en estas elecciones
el 3 de noviembre de tomarse el voto en
serio por parte de la población también
hizo un recuento de la importancia el
voto de la mujer cuando hoy se cumplen
100 años de que las mujeres pueden votar
en eeuu también habló del lines de la
unidad del país habló también sobre el
existe el servicio postal de eeuu esta
polémica que hay con este sistema postal
en el país que los demócratas acusaban
de que el presidente y las directivas
del servicio postal estaban retrasando
lo para entorpecer un poco las
elecciones el presidente
donald trump también hablaba de que con
estas elecciones por correo se podría
cometer fraude pero ella él el director
de este servicio postal fue aclarar en
el congreso de eeuu y dijo que no se iba
a hacer ningún cambio entonces en el
servicio postal si no después
de las elecciones por toda esta polémica
que se generó antes también habló de que
bardem iba a trabajar por una energía
limpia en el país hablando un poco sobre
el cambio climático a lo mejor también
retomar algunos algunos pactos que había
afirmado eeuu de los cuales salió como
el del acuerdo de parís también habló
sobre baiden y que él prometió un
salario justo para los trabajadores
habló también de los una protección de
empleo para los pequeños comerciantes
también ayuda al gobierno para los
pequeños comerciantes que se han
derrumbado y muchos han quebrado por
esta pandemia de el coronavirus en eeuu
que ha golpeado con fuerza en ese país
ya van más de 170 mil muertos por esta
pandemia también habló de la seguridad y
votar por la justicia esto entonces un
resumen de las palabras de hillary
clinton la ex candidata presidencial en
el año 2016 hay que recordar que gira
ganó el voto popular en esa en esa
oportunidad de las elecciones de 2016
cuando se enfrentó al actual presidente
de donald trump pero perdió en los
colegios en el electorales en el país
por un margen de menos de 200.000 votos
y según también lo mencionó en en el
discurso en el primer día de la
convención
michelle obama personal en algunos
colegios electorales hasta por dos votos
o la diferencia mínima entonces ahora ya
está todo listo para escuchar a la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi
y la mayoría más diversa en la historia
más tiene 60 por ciento de mujeres y
personas de color
en nuestra diversidad en nuestra
fortaleza en nuestra unidad es nuestro
poder este mes
mientras en eeuu marca el primer siglo
del voto femenino
tenemos a varias mujeres en la cámara de
representante y orgullosamente 90 de
ellas son mujeres las mujeres nunca se
han dado por vencidas estamos en sus
espaldas llevando el trabajo que no
habían terminado
desde cero esto hace cuatro años cuando
el presidente obama y el vicepresidente
joe biden estaban en la casa blanca nos
hicieron sentir orgullosas hicieron
nuestro país maravilloso y ese espíritu
está con nosotros ahora no para
llevarnos hacia la oscuridad sino hacia
adelante ese es el propósito de guiar es
de los demócratas luchar por la gente
hemos impulsado proyectos de ley para
subir los salarios y para proteger los
derechos y por ejemplo llevar a la
justicia a la muerte de charles white la
equidad de la comunidad lgbt y para
preservar nuestro planeta generaciones
futuras e incluso mucho más todo esto es
posible para eeuu quien está en el
camino
mitch mcconnell y donald front nuestra
nación enfrenta la peor catástrofe en
nuestra historia
con millones de personas infectadas con
el coronavirus y 170.000 muertos los
héroes que han estado actuando es
esencial seguir guardando sus vidas y la
vida de nuestra democracia y quien se
está interponiendo mitch mcconnell y
donald friendster en vez de aplastar el
virus están aplastando al obama y los
beneficios de las enfermedades
preexistentes he visto el irrespeto que
donald trump hace a las mujeres en
particular si que se traduce en sus
políticas y en nuestros derechos y en
nuestra salud no solo en su conducta
pero sabemos lo que no es lo que él no
sabe que cuando las mujeres tienen éxito
en eeuu tiene éxito así que llevamos el
poder de las mujeres para llevarlo a
nuestra vida nacional para que las
mujeres puedan defenderse y estén con un
cuidado seguro y fácil para sus niños
con un sueldo equitativo pero quién está
interponiéndose mitch mcconnell y donald
trump
así que quieres nuestra respuesta vamos
a recordarlo en noviembre cuando
elijamos a iovine en presidente
su corazón está lleno de amor por eeuu
y por el bien de eeuu joe biden y tiene
la valentía para liberar tiene el amor
para perseverar joe biden es el
presidente que necesitamos ahora que
mira hacia adelante honesto y auténtico
que nunca ha olvidado por quién está
peleando y kamala harris es la
vicepresidenta que necesitamos ahora
comprometida con nuestra constitución
brillante una persona que ha sido
testigo de las voces de esta nación y
que mostrará cómo se escucharán nuestra
misión es luchar por el futuro y por los
ideales de nuestros fundadores a darle
esperanza a nuestros niños por los
sacrificios de nuestros veteranos
y sus familias vamos a incrementar
nuestra mayoría en la cámara de
representantes y en el senado y vamos a
elegir a kamala harris vicepresidente
joe biden presidente de los eeuu de
américa a dios los bendiga y dios
bendiga a eeuu
nancy pelosi la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes en eeuu importantísima
en el dentro del partido demócrata
quiero entonces darle la palabra a
nuestra mujer invitada ella es michel
manatt analista política estratega
demócrata y ex asesora del departamento
de estado de eeuu hablemos entonces de
la importancia del voto femenino en eeuu
además con la llegada de kamala harris a
la posible llegada de kamala harris a la
vicepresidencia del país y también
siendo una mujer afroamericana
bueno quiero sobrar unas cosas que dijo
la la nuestra es picar la la jefa número
uno la jefa responsable de todo en la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi mi
amiga nancy pelosi de california como yo
ella nos dijo que hay ahora 150 mujeres
en la cámara de representantes 150 150
en todos 115 en total 115 en total de
estos 115 90 son demócratas entonces
hacemos la madre de la cav del cálculo
no la cantidad de mujeres electos del
partido republicano en 2020 son 25 eso
es algo incomprensible en una democracia
moderna que lo que es nuestro país yo
trabajé como asesora en el congreso con
mucho orgullo en los años 90 y cuando yo
estaba trabajando ahí había un 30% más o
menos de mujeres electos en la cámara y
más o menos igualdad entre los dos
partidos ahora nosotros demócratas
estamos en una posición de máximo máxima
posición de números en comparación con
el otro partido nuestros contrincantes
eso es algo fundamental que representa
el caos y la decadencia del partido
republicano
lamentable digo yo una demócrata ok
también quiero subrayar la importancia
de este momento de ayer que la fecha de
ayer fue la el aniversario 100 años
desde que llegamos a la posibilidad de
votar más que 50 por ciento de la
población así que creo que ya sabemos
que las mujeres nosotras llegamos a un
punto de poder que representa este
momento con esta noche muy importante y
como como el punto final de y también el
punto de donde empieza si la búsqueda
del poder la relacionadora cámara como
la jerez como la jerez que representa el
del del estado de california california
que es un estado multi racial en este
momento
el presente y el futuro
punto final ella es lo que representa
que nos nos presenta el otro partido el
partido republicano nos presenta dos
hombres blancos blancos y de 5 60 y 70
años la cámara al xerez es una abogada
fue
una es una abogada formada en la en la
universidad de california hastings uno
de los dos clubs facultades de derecho
mejores en el país ella ha sido un
servidor pública toda su vida en
comparación con el presidente de donald
trump que fue un business mens nada más
nunca fue un servidor público así que
vemos el contraste en contraste es obvio
obvio y
algo de uno no puede evaluarlo es
imposible minimizar el contraste entre
los dos partidos en este momento así que
tenemos y estamos en el momento del
despegue para aprovechar y honrar lo que
es eeuu en 2020 en 2020 somos un país
multirracial somos un país de
inmigrantes de todo el planeta y somos
un país
y más jóvenes y jóvenes que quieren
participar en las elecciones yo creo con
nuestro nuestra fórmula nuestro ticket
tebaida liniers vamos a incentivar a una
votación masiva quiero ahora darle la
palabra al señor godo él es analista
republicano y ex vocero en español de la
campaña presidencial de ted cruz en el
estado de la florida y se encuentra en
la ciudad de miami estábamos escuchando
entonces a la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi hablando de
mitch mcconnell y donald trump
poniéndolos como una especie de
obstáculo o obstáculos masculinos ante
la llegada de una vicepresidenta a la
casa a brac a la casa blanca además una
afroamericana qué opinión le merece
bueno en primer lugar de kamala harris
no es afroamericana ella no tiene origen
africano por ninguna parte
que observa su procedencia viene de
jamaica así que este menos afroamericano
no aplica es una mujer que tiene un
antes oscura en la piel pero no es
afroamericana
es normal que se quiera buscar el voto
femenino y el voto hispano
o sea eso los políticos yo les aceptó
que está mal por supuesto que tras de
manipular cuando hablo o sea no lo puedo
entender
aún cuando mienten o manipulen los datos
y a la opinión pública para tratar de
ganarse ese ese voto
sino no fueron políticos pero una cosa
es eso cuando venimos por ejemplo en
medio como este debemos tratar de ser lo
más honesto posible y debemos tratar de
informarnos bien para no decir cosas o
estar repitiendo cosas que se saben que
no son ciertas
y se siguen repitiendo y hay un viejo
proverbio por ahí que dice cuando tú
repite muchas veces la mentira se
convierte en verdad por ejemplo para el
voto hispano
donde hay muchas mujeres hispanas que
acabo de ver en el vídeo que manifiestan
que quieren votar por byd y una de las
cosas de los ganchos mayores de la
defensa de los inmigrantes
indocumentados que son inmigrantes
ilegales indocumentados dejó un cliché
en términos bastante
un nacional pero al final no están
legalmente en el país y qué es lo que
pasa se dice por ejemplo las famosas
aulas y la separación de niños en la
frontera en primer lugar la separación
de niños en la frontera en su inmensa
mayoría ni los separos ni los separó
obama ni lo separo nadie lo separa no
sus mismos padres que lo mandaron solos
a la frontera irresponsablemente niños
menores
y que es que tú puedes esperar de un
padre que haga eso con su hijo se sabe
que la inmensa mayoría de esos niños
fueron separados por sus padres antes o
después de llegar ahí porque no les
importaba ahora hablando del tema de las
aulas que quiere quieren seguir ganando
el voto hispano en las aulas empezó a
acusar a trump ya que hablas en la
frontera todavía en el 2020 las personas
que están diciendo que fueron cuando las
fotos que se pusieron eran falsas
grandes 2014 de 2014 el presidente de la
uam que fue que hizo esas aulas en el
2020 sí que todavía estás diciendo de
eso entonces deberíamos informarnos un
poquito más para no repetir lo que
siente incluso ayer la agencia apf
desmintió el discurso de michelle obama
cuando siguió diciendo eso y la agencia
velada michelle obama busquen los cables
hoy que esas aulas estaban desde el 2014
por favor entonces para para seguir
demonizando a trump independientemente
usted puede atacar al ron con lo que
quiera pero por favor ataque luego cosas
que sean y que sean y que sean siempre
se habla de política cuando incluya
igualadas hablan de siguen buscando
cuatro hispanos
e incluso de las mujeres
y que instauró una política de no
tolerancia hacia los hispanos cuando él
llegó a la casa nada que escuchar cuando
el señor obama deportó a casi 3 millones
de hispanos porque los mismos medios que
hablan de la política de 'cero
tolerancia' de trump hacia los hispanos
no mencionan que el señor obama fue
conocido por el deportado en jefe y
punto por la presidencia nacional de una
organización hispana para celebrar que
creo que es real es mucho que ella misma
es demócrata lo catalogó de portadora
jefe porque está deportando a todos los
hispanos entonces siguen con la retórica
de que tron es el enemigo de los
hispanos bueno que consejo gana entonces
porque obama deportó a más hispanos que
tú cuarenta y pico de presidentes
anteriores juntos y eso en cuanto a eso
en cuanto a la mujer
por supuesto que fue una gran conquista
que las mujeres no pudieron votar en
1920 e incluso luchadora en ese
movimiento como el de susana antúnes que
cuestionaron cuando se hizo la
decimocuarta enmienda en 1868 déjenos
que está bien vamos a darle el derecho
al voto de los ciudadanos negros por
ciento extienda aprobada por los
republicanos pero pero porque si se le
va a dar el voto a los ciudadanos negros
porque no se le da voto a las mujeres
tanto negras como blancas o sea ella con
toda su razón dijeron eso en aquel
momento las mujeres tuvieron que pasar
mucho para llegar a donde llegaron para
obtener su derecho a votar y hoy en día
están en todos los puestos en este más
inclinable de que aquí hay
discriminación a la mujer de alguna
manera por favor tenemos mujeres y yo
tenemos mujeres en arquitectos e
ingenieros en todas partes mujeres
millonarias en el depósito y mujeres de
la raza negra millonaria
en el deporte o sea manipular el voto
hispano es muy fácil la única reforma
migratoria aquí la hizo ron arriba en
1986 le dio papeles a más de 3 millones
de personas porque nos dicen eso los
medios y les sigue echando la culpa a
los republicanos de la tangana ningún
presidente demócrata eso aquí reforma
migratoria lo que pasa 9 cuando se le
dan los papeles a las personas y dejan y
no tienes una política en la frontera
para controlar que sigan entrando
personas ilegales entonces cuando pasen
un montón de años tienes el mismo
problema y ese fue el error en aquel
momento de terry a lo que vamos a
legalizar a las personas que están aquí
pero vamos a cerrar el grifo para que
hay un orden de inmigración en este país
pero por favor no no me gustan las
manipulaciones y las cosas cuando no se
basan en hechos reales pero ver vamos a
hacer un poquito más honesto empezando
por los políticos y decir las cosas con
hechos reales las cosas que están
ocurriendo para lo llevamos uniendo como
demócratas y republicanos y podemos dar
sensatamente y no vota por una
manipulación señor godoy yo me refería a
la señora sabes la candidata a la
vicepresidencia como afroamericana
porque así ella misma se identifica
porque su papá es de origen jamaiquino y
la mamá es de india y ella hablaba de
que es la primera asiática americana y
áfrica americana de llegar a la
presidencia de aspirar a la
vicepresidencia de eeuu y era por esa
razón entonces que la que identificamos
como como una mujer afroamericana porque
así ella misma se identifica señor gol
pero lo dejó por un momento y quiero ir
con el señor patricio zamorano también
analista internacional desde la ciudad
washington y si la capital
estadounidense para hablar un poco sobre
la economía de eeuu golpeada por esta
pandemia de kobe 19 que es el tema que
están tratando actualmente en la
convención es demócrata y el tema a
seguir que como cree usted que está la
economía en este momento en eeuu y cómo
se puede recuperar
sí bueno muchas gracias yo te quería
hacer varias grabaciones de la cantidad
de información
hablando de manipulación de la cantidad
de información que sea que se ha dado en
estos últimos minutos tienes efectiva
primero aclarar de la manera más rotunda
posible que se cometió el error en casi
todos los medios hispanos del planeta
kamala harris no es la primera
vicepresidenta y candidata a la
vicepresidenta afectando unidense ya no
lo es
hubo una antes este año justamente la
candidata a vicepresidenta del partido
verde ángela walker que se eligió en
julio en una convención de más de 300
delegados del partido verde y antes de
ellas dos de cámaras graves y anyela
walker ha habido una docena de otras
estadounidenses y mujeres líderes negras
entre ellas la famosa angela davis que
también fue candidata a vicepresidenta
hace 20 años atrás entonces es una
distorsión de la información señalar que
camela que dice es la primera
afroestadounidense hay que celebrar su
integración en una fórmula presidencial
que sin duda expande el voto para hayden
efectivamente ella se reconoce como
afroestadounidense y como asiática
también así que eso es importantísimo en
la presencia de la mujer pero para
aclarar ella no es absolutamente no es
la primera afroamericana en ese cargo de
candidata y otra cosa importante me han
llegado una cantidad enorme de
comunicaciones en los medios sociales
que la nasa lo ha dicho claramente y la
nasa no es de izquierda que concordaran
los dos analistas que me acompañan la
nasa ha señalado que no hay ninguna duda
que del siglo 19 cuando empieza la alta
emisión de carbono de dióxido de carbono
por la acción del hombre el efecto de
calentamiento global se ha aumentado de
manera exponencial negar eso es una
ignorancia extrema
típica de donald trump que no cree en
los científicos
tenemos que describir cuál ha sido la
situación horrenda durante la crisis de
el coronavirus con un presidente que
básicamente boicoteado a sus propios
científicos ha boicoteado a sus propias
organizaciones médicas y todavía no da
una señal de que hay que usar
mascarillas la cantidad de gente que ha
muerto en los eeuu más de 175.000
personas esa es una responsabilidad
tremenda y que tiene que ver con esta
esta manía de no de no hacer caso a el
tema científico señor interrumpo
interempresa momento para ir con
elisabeth warren y vuelvo con usted que
penn interrumpirlo vamos con elizabeth
warren
golpe atrás otros iguales babies
la educación para los más jóvenes mods
ha estado cerrados durante meses ya era
difícil antes de la pandemia encontrar
cuidado para los demonios y ahora los
padres
atrapado sin saber cuándo y qué opciones
tienen para la educación de sus hijos la
forma en la que lo veo es que los
problemas grandes demandan soluciones
grandes
[Música]
y tiene grandes planes planes para
volver a traer los trabajos y la
manufactura y crear los empleos con
energía limpia con más beneficios para
los trabajadores y trabajar para las
familias en vez de las instituciones
crediticias nuestro sistema económico le
ha dado beneficios a los millonarios y
problemas a los demás pero podemos
construir una mejor economía e invertir
en las familias y arreglar lo que está
roto
nuestros planes de yo para hacer la
economía mejor
y hace que las empresas sean
responsables y repara la inequidad
racial y además lucha contra la
corrupción en washington déjenme
decirles un plan de joe biden que es muy
especial para mi corazón el cuidado para
los niños lo que más quería yo cuando
era niña era ser una maestra me encanta
enseñar en texas a los niños fue mi
primer trabajo
y me ha salvado ha sido de mayor cuidado
de los niños un día mi tía ya no
solamente para ver cómo yo estaba y
pensó que estaba bien pero yo me rompí y
empecé a llorar estaba tratando de
mantenerlo dentro de mí pero si no es
mío y dado como para los niños era
imposible trabajar le dije que iba a
renunciar a mi trabajo mientras mi
corazón se rompiese
y luego me dijo las palabras que
cambiaron mi vida no puedo llegar mañana
pero llegaré a la presencia y llegó
consciente
y se quedó durante 16
yo estoy aquí esta noche gracias a mí
y aprendí una verdad fundamental nadie
lo hace solo y aquí estamos dos
generaciones de padres que trabajan y si
usted tiene un hijo y no tiene una tía
está solo en ti esto está mal hemos
construido una infraestructura y
sistemas de comunicaciones para que las
personas puedan trabajar y eso nos ayuda
a todos porque hace que la economía
funcione pero es momento de reconocer
que el cuidado de esos niños es parte de
esta infraestructura básica de nuestra
relación para las familias yo y cámara
van a hacer que el cuidado para los
niños sea accesible a todas las familias
que sea la escuela primaria y el
preescolar sea universal esto es solo un
plan pero les da la idea de cómo haremos
que este país funcione para todos
la ignorancia y la incompetencia de
donald trump han sido siempre un peligro
para nuestro país el commit 19 fue la
prueba más grande para trump bis y la
perdió miserablemente hoy eeuu que la
mayor parte de las muertes del joven 19
en el mundo y un colapso económico que
están pasando además una factura mayor
para las familias negras y latinas hay
muchas personas en riesgo de perder sus
hogares sus tiendas están frente a una
amenaza y esta crisis es muy terrible y
no tenía que ser así esta crisis es de
los republicanos y de donald trump
el 3 de noviembre vamos a hacer que
todos ellos paguen por su
responsabilidad así que van a votar con
una mascarilla o por correo tomen sus
teléfono ahora y manda en un mensaje al
con la palabra voto al 30
3 debemos hacer que yo y camela sean
elegidos y después de noviembre
necesitamos seguir luchando para que las
cosas grandes se hagan y seguimos en
esta pelea para que cuando nuestros
hijos y nuestros nietos nos pregunten
que hicimos durante este capítulo
sombrío de nuestra historia los podamos
mirar directamente a los ojos y decirles
nos organizamos persistimos y cambiamos
a eeuu
elizabeth warren ex aspirante a la casa
blanca por parte del partido demócrata
habló enfocó su discurso más que todo en
el cuidado de los niños también habló
sobre la pandemia del coi 19 que azota
fuertemente a eeuu con más de 170 mil
fallecidos por esta pandemia dijo que
fue un fallo republicano y un fallo del
presidente donald trump todo esto todo
esto lo que está ocurriendo con la
pandemia de coronavirus tanto en la vida
de las personas como también en la parte
económica del país dijo que había un
plan en el en el plan de gobierno de joe
biden para asegurar a los niños ya las
familias el preescolar y la primaria
para todos que sea un plan universal
para todos los estadounidenses
también dijo que el kobe 19 la pandemia
del cob y 19 afecta fuertemente a las
comunidades afroamericanas y también a
la comunidad latina en ese país y por
supuesto llamado entonces a votar por
kamala harris y a votar por donald trump
y antes de la intervención de elizabeth
warren estábamos hablando con patricio
zamorano señor zamora no tiene usted la
palabra para que retomen lo que habíamos
dejado antes sobre la economía del país
debido a esta pandemia de kobe 19 como
se ha contraído la economía
estadounidense que además era la carta
de presentación más fuerte del
presidente de donald trump durante toda
toda su presidencia durante su campaña y
ahora entonces que que es que va a ser
el presidente dentro con la economía
estadounidense para así llegar a esos
votos que votan por el presidente por la
economía
bueno yo diría que en ese sentido donald
trans se ha perjudicado a sí mismo con
una política totalmente errática para
atacar y contrarrestar los efectos de
una virus no todos sabemos no hay nada
que discutir de la forma errática que se
ha comportado en estos últimos meses y
que ha provocado una de las caídas más
fuertes de la historia de los eeuu un 30
por ciento en la caída del producto
interno bruto en el último trimestre 40
millones más de 40 millones de
estadounidenses sin empleo
de una repercusión enorme también en la
gente que no tiene seguro médico entre
40 y 50 millones de estado de hace que
todavía no tiene seguro médico por lo
menos os vamos a creer que era el
programa que había puesto en práctica el
presente obama sentado a cubrir parte de
esa falencia así que la verdad es que 2
donald trump
con la forma en que ha ejercido su lucha
contra el coronavirus errática caótica
no ha logrado frenarlo y no ha logrado
reactivar a la economía y eso por su
porfía de no entender las razones
científicas boicotear a sus propias
autoridades sanitarias en europa tuvo su
curva dos meses y ya viene mejorando de
una manera significativa a eeuu cuando
llegó ese momento en que había que
seguir con políticas razonables
inteligentes donald también empujó para
que se abriera el país ahora está en de
una manera irresponsable intentando que
los niños vuelvan a las salas de clases
los científicos están advirtiendo que va
a provocar una situación peor entonces
la verdad
eeuu debió haber terminado esta crisis
hace un mes y al contrario se ha
expandido dos o tres meses más hasta que
haya una vacuna entonces la verdad es
que
es posible que este país repunte si
logra controlar el coronavirus y donald
trump entiende lo que debe hacer es
posible que la economía incluso se
mejore y es posible que les beneficia
electoralmente así que en ese sentido
donald trump se ha disparado a sus hilos
bio pie con la forma en que se ha
desenvuelto en nuestros últimos meses sí
señor zamora no vamos ahora con las
declaraciones del ex presidente barack
obama
ahora esta no es una convención normal
como lo han visto es no es un momento
normal así que esta noche quiero hablar
tan simple como sea posible sobre lo que
está en juego en esta elección porque lo
que hacemos
estos hagamos estos días va a ser hacer
eco durante las generaciones 109
filadelfia donde se firmó nuestra
constitución por facebook y no fue un
documento perfecto
y tampoco le dio a las personas a las
mujeres la posibilidad de votar
pero en ese documento había un borrador
al comienzo del sistema tomamos una
democracia
a través de la cual íbamos a revisar
nuestros ideales más grandes sucedido
a través de las luchas y la guerra civil
mejoramos esta constitución para incluir
las voces de aquellos que dejamos por
fuera y gradualmente hicimos este país
más justo y más equitativo y más libre
o la oficina
constitucional elegida por toda la gente
es la presidencia y por eso debemos
esperar que la persona que ocupe este
cargo sienta la responsabilidad de todos
los millones de habitantes de este país
sin importar cómo nos veamos aclamemos
cuanto dinero tengamos como nos veamos o
por quién votamos también podemos
esperar que el presidente sea el
guardián de esta constitución que más
allá del ego de la ambición de sus
creencias políticas el presidente va a
preservar a proteger y defender la
libertad y los ideales de todos los
estadounidenses y los que marcharon
fueron a la cárcel por estos ideales y
pelearon por estos ideales
me senté en la oficina oval con los dos
hombres que están compitiendo por la
pasión y nunca esperé que mi sucesor
para trazar la medición del mundo o
continuará con mis políticas esperaba
por el bien de nuestro país
que donald trump mostrará algún interés
en tomarse el trabajo en serio
que sintiera el peso de la oficina y
descubriera alguna atrocidad a un
respaldo a la democracia que ha sido
puesta a su cuidado pero nunca lo hizo
casi durante cuatro años no ha mostrado
ningún interés con el trabajo en
encontrar una base confusión
todo el poder maravilloso que tiene en
esta oficina para ayudar a alguien más
que a sí mismo ya sus amigos ningún
interés en tratar a la presidencia como
nada más que un reality show que puede
usar para tomar la atención que anhela
donald trump no ha crecido en este
trabajo porque no puede hacerlo y las
consecuencias de ese fracaso son severas
170.000 estadounidenses muertos millones
de trabajos se han perdido y los que
están arriba están ganando más que nunca
en pozos sándwiches nuestros peores
impulsos han sido liberados nuestra
reputación de la que nos enorgullecíamos
en el mundo ha sido desvanecida wall en
nuestras instituciones democráticas
están amenazadas como nunca antes
ahora sé que en momentos tan polarizados
como estos la mayoría de ustedes ya han
tomado una decisión pero tal vez no
están seguros de a quién darle su voto o
si siquiera van a votar tal vez están
cansados de la dirección hacia dónde
vamos
lo suficiente sobre la persona que nos
quiere llevar en este camino
pero déjenme hablarles de mi amigo joe
biden
hace 12 años que empecé a buscar al
vicepresidente no no sabía que iba a
encontrar a un hermano
ella y yo venimos de lugares diferentes
de generaciones diferentes cuerpo y
kmart pero llegué muy rápidamente a
admirar su resiliencia nació de mucha
lucha su empatía su gimnasio de mucho
dolor
él aprendió muy rápidamente a tratar a
todas las personas a las que conocía con
respeto y dignidad porque eso lo que le
enseñaron sus padres
eres mejor que nadie con esa empatía y
esa decencia la creencia de que todos
cuentan suyos ese es quien es
cuando hablas con alguien que ha perdido
su trabajo se recuerda se acuerda de la
noche en la que su padre le contó lo
mismo cuando yo escucha a un padre que
está tratando de mantenerse en pie dos y
hermes escucha como un padre soltero
tomaba su tren cada noche para poder ir
a acostar a sus hijos
cuando se encuentra con las familias de
militares que perdieron a su vuelo lo
hace con un espíritu amable como el
padre de un soldado estadounidense cuya
fe ha enfrentado la pérdida más grande
que hay
durante ocho años él fue el último en
irse cuando yo enfrentaba una decisión
de griselda records él me hizo a mí o
mejorar sidor y tiene él
y la experiencia de hacernos a nosotros
un mejor país y mi amiga anna jarvis
eligió en ella
una compañera ideal que está aún más que
preparada para el trabajo alguien que
sabe que es superar barreras que ha
hecho una carrera luchando para ayudar a
los otros a vivir su propio sueño
americano
con la experiencia que se necesita para
hacer las cosas
ambos tienen informaran políticas que
van a hacer un país más fuerte una
realidad
van a controlar eso como lo hizo conmigo
para el h1n1 y el ébola
van a llevar el cuidado de salud a más
estadounidenses como me ayuda a hacerlo
hace unos años cuando él logró los votos
para hacerlo una ley para rescatar la
economía como me ayudó a hacer
hasta después cuando creamos los mayores
empleos de la historia y vemos esto como
una oportunidad no para volver a donde
estábamos
sino para hacer grandes cambios para que
nuestra economía sea un poco más fácil
para adultos ya sea una mesera que está
tratando de criar un niño
trabaja por turnos
un estudiante que está tratando de
encontrar cómo va a pagar las clases del
próximo semestre
carmela van a restaurar nuestro lugar
aprendimos de esta pandemia que eso
importa él conoce el mundo y el mundo lo
conoce a él
sabe que nuestra fuerza verdadera viene
de mostrar y ser un ejemplo que el medio
quiere una nación que está con la
democracia no con los dictadores
una nación que pueda inspirar y
movilizar a otros
a superar el terrorismo y amenazas como
la pobreza el cambio climático las
enfermedades
pero más que nada lo que sé
lo que sé de esto es que realmente les
importa a cada uno de los
estadounidenses y que se preocupan
profundamente por esta democracia
ellos creen que en una democracia el
derecho a votar es sagrado y lo
deberíamos hacer más fácil para las
personas no más difícil
ellos creen que nadie ni siquiera el
presente está sobre la ley en que ningún
funcionario incluido el presidente
debería usar su cargo
para hacerse más rico o asus usted de
personas aliadas porque entiende que en
esta democracia el comandante en jefe no
usa a los hombres y mujeres de nuestro
fuerza militar que están dispuestos a
hacer todo lo posible por nuestra nación
para controlar a nuestro en nuestro
propio suelo a manifestantes pacíficos
entienden que en nuestros oponentes no
son los propios estadounidenses solo
porque están muy en desacuerdo que
nosotros
y están dispuestos a trabajar juntos
para resolver un problema grande como
una pandemia
a través de los hechos como lógica y la
ciencia no simplemente inventando cosas
y nada de esto debería ser controversial
esto no debería ser principios
republicanos o demócratas
estadounidenses y en este movimiento
este presidente no suena igual y
aquellos que lo apoyan
han mostrado que no creen en estas cosas
esta noche les estoy pidiendo que crean
joe y en cámara en su capacidad de sacar
a este país de estos tiempos oscuros y
llevarlos a un momento mejor pero esto
es lo que deben saber ningún
estadounidense puede arreglar este país
solo ni siquiera un presidente la
democracia no debió hacer una
transacción tú me das tu voto y yo hago
todo mejor requiere una ciudadanía
activa e información así que también les
pido que crean en su propia habilidad de
adueñarse en su responsabilidad como
ciudadanos deben asegurarse de que se
mantengan nuestra democracia porque eso
es lo que está en juego ahora si nuestra
democracia
miren yo entiendo por qué muchos
estadounidenses están decepcionados del
gobierno la forma de las reglas han sido
abusados y que han detenido el progreso
dos personas de fábrica se pueden sentir
como que el gobierno ya no los pueda
porque una mujer luego puede pensar que
nunca la cuidaron
porque pueden llegar y preguntarse si
aún hay lugar para él en este país como
es una persona joven puede mirar a la
política y ons discursos a las mentiras
a la conspiración a las teorías y decir
cuál es el punto
pues este es el punto este presidente y
los que están en el poder los que se
benefician de mantener las cosas como
están
están viendo por su ciudad saben que
pueden cuando mantienen sus políticas y
están haciendo lo más difícil posible
para que ustedes voten y para
convencerlos de que su voto no importa
así es como ganan así es como ellos
siguen haciendo las decisiones que
afectan sus vidas y las personas y la
vida de las personas que ustedes aman y
mantener la economía para los ricos
y para que nuestro sistema de salud no
reciba a las personas y se vayan por las
brechas que así se mina la democracia
hasta que ya no queda ninguna y no
podemos permitir que esto pase y no
dejen que les quiten su poder
no dejen que les quiten su democracia y
que hagan un plan ahora sobre cómo se
van a involucrar a votar
hágalo tan pronto como puedan y dígale a
su familia ya sus amigos cómo pueden
votar
hagan lo que los estadounidenses han
hecho durante más de 200 ciclos cuando
han enfrentado incluso tiempos más
difíciles que estos todos estos héroes
en silencio que encontraron la valentía
para seguir empujando a seguir marchando
contra la injusticia
el mes pasado perdimos una parte
importantísima del área y algunos
líderes del movimiento de los derechos
civiles uno de ellos me dijo que nunca
imaginaría que caminaría en la casa
blanca y verá vería un accidente que se
viera como su abuelo y me dijo que no
estaba bien y que en el día en el que yo
nací él estábamos entrando a una cárcel
para pedir el fin de la segregación
segregación racial
lo que nosotros hacemos tiene un eco en
las generaciones
sin importar de donde vengamos todos
somos los hijos de estadounidenses que
lucharon la pelea correcta nuestros
abuelos que aguantaron sin derechos o
representación
vamos granjeros que perdieron sus sueños
los vieron hacerse los irlandeses
italianos latinos asiáticos
a quienes se les ha hecho sentirse se
han visto sospechosas sports a quien
adora los afroamericanos que cambiaron y
se mantuvieron espero aunque fueran
escupidas por sentarse a almorzar
golpeados por tratar de votar
en igual si él tiene un derecho
para creer que esta democracia no
funciona eran ellos nuestros ancestros
ellos estaban recibiendo una democracia
que no había hecho nada por ellos
durante todos ellos la realidad de eeuu
y en vez de darse por vencidos se
unieron y dijeron que de alguna manera
iban a hacer que funcionara
dos words iban a llevar igual estas
palabras en nuestros documentos de
fundación a la vida he visto ese mismo
espíritu levantarse en estos otros dos
años personas de todas las edades que
vienen de todas partes en aeropuertos en
las vidas
donde sus familias son separadas o en
otros salen de clases recibiendo
disparos para que nuestros niños no
crezcan en un mundo que no sea habitable
estadounidenses de todas las razas
uniendo sus rostros uniéndose para
enfrentar a la injusticia a la
brutalidad de manos del estado
el movimiento black light
para que ningún niño en este país sienta
el racismo
a los jóvenes
que nos dijeron este verano que nosotros
necesitamos ser mejores
ustedes son el sueño hecho realidad de
este país
otras generaciones tenían que ser
persuadidas
se les tenía que convencer de que tenían
una voz y para ustedes es un don o agua
una convicción y lo que quiero que sepan
es que a través de toda esta frustración
esto su sistema de autogobierno
puede llevarlos a realizar estas
condiciones para todos nosotros
y ustedes le pueden dar en nuestra
democracia no significa que ustedes
pueden llevarla a un mejor lugar
ustedes son el ingrediente que falta web
los que van a decidir si eeuu son se
convierte en el país que vive en
realidad a su reputación y a su máximo
potencial este trabajo va a continuar
mucho más allá de esta elección
pero cualquier opción de éxito depende
del resultado de esta elección
esta administración ha demostrado que va
a romper nuestra democracia si eso es lo
que necesita hacer para ganar así que
tenemos que trabajar y sacar todos
nuestros esfuerzos en estas semanas y
votaron como nunca lo hemos hecho antes
porque hoy
we live para que no dejemos ninguna duda
sobre lo que este país que amamos
significa y representa hoy
y para los próximos días por venir
manténganse a salvo fraguas dios los
bendiga
ahí lo digan ustedes entonces era el ex
presidente barack obama haciendo su
discurso en este tercer día de
convención demócrata recordemos que es
de manera virtual debido a esta pandemia
de coronavirus que estamos viviendo
todos a nivel mundial empezó hablando de
la constitución de eeuu dijo que una
constitución que el presidente actual
donald trump nunca respetó que no mostró
interés ni respeto por el trabajo
refiriéndose al trabajo de el presidente
dijo que hizo del salón oval y de la
casa blanca un reality show y convirtió
a la presidencia en un reality show y
que trump no puede crecer en ese trabajo
porque simplemente no puede después de
estos ataques que además han sido un
poco inusual por parte del ex presidente
barack obama contra el actual presidente
de donald trump empezó a hablar de el
candidato joe biden quien fue su
vicepresidente durante su mandato dijo
que no sólo había encontrado a una buena
fórmula
sino que también encontró a un hermano
hablo de la empatía que tiene el
candidato bailén dijo que él escuchaba
que tenía dignidad que trataba a las
personas con respeto que tiene mucha
decencia
también habló que joe biden va a
rescatar la economía del país como ayudó
al ex presidente barack obama en luego
de la recesión económica del 2008 a
recuperar la economía todo esto porque
recordemos que la economía
estadounidense está sufriendo por culpa
de l de kobe de 19 también dijo que iba
a hacer de estados unidos un mejor país
dijo que iba a ayudar a salir a eeuu a
controlar la pandemia de coronavirus
como lo hizo en aquel entonces también
cuando obama estaba al frente en la
presidencia con el virus de la
influencia y pues también dijo que la
cámara jarvis ya joe biden importaba
cada estadounidense que cada
estadounidense le importa
joe biden y también a kamala harris
vamos entonces a analizar un poco del
discurso del ex presidente barack obama
quiero empezar y ahora con fernando godo
el analista político republicano está en
la ciudad de la pena de miami en el
estado de la florida señor godo estoy
con usted para entonces saber su
reacción y su opinión luego de que
escuchamos el discurso del ex presidente
obama
si mira me estás escuchando bien bueno
si en primera decirte que estás
conduciendo magníficamente bien y las
preguntas están excelentes o sea no
quiero hacer eso que dicen te como en
ningún momento antes cuando lo era para
dejar de decir que es ponerlo de su hijo
de ninguna manera yo sé que es ella la
que se autodefine así lo quería claras
desordenadamente solicitó con la
conducción entre el discurso de obama
bueno tiene con zonas de manipulación tú
no puedes decir que las protestas parado
desde sus bocas son pacíficas hay
negocios de hispanos y de personas de la
raza negra destruidos por los
manifestantes en varias ciudades de los
eeuu
entonces como tú te vas a parar a
alguien a decirme siendo un ex
presidente de este país por favor que
las manifestaciones son pacíficas vamos
a respetar un poquito más la
inteligencia de ciudadano de los estados
unidos
eso es en primer lugar lo otro es la
manipulación discutimos del tema racial
el tema racial es un tema que de largo
como dónde cortar el hijo que había
encontrado en iuvalé un hermano yo no
dudo que se encontraron en mano pero los
dos tienen vídeo en youtube que se puede
ver fueron al velorio al funeral del
senador robert ver que fue un miembro
activo de ku kux klan los estados unidos
y fue presidente del senado con muchos
años la parte demócrata y que murió en
el 2010 siendo presidente obama y
estando todavía como senador en el
congreso de los eeuu
como como siendo en un defensor o hamaca
este caso supuestamente de los derechos
de las personas de raza negra los eeuu
vas a ir a un velorio de ese señor y así
que fue un gran hombre cuando fue un
líder reclutado de cv muscular en los
años 50 senador robert ver que murió con
93 años y bardem también tuvo palabras
en ese humedal y hillary clinton también
entonces hasta dónde llega la hipocresía
de la lucha yo tengo muchos vídeos en
internet sobre la defensa de los
ciudadanos negros los estados en ese
porque me indigna lo que le hizo el
partido demócrata para los ciudadanos
negros los eeuu y nunca se disculparon
por eso el partido demócrata se opuso
tenazmente a la abolición de la
esclavitud fueron los republicanos los
que llevaron efectos eso sí tuvo que
haber una guerra cambiaria y una guerra
civil que no fue la última única causa
de la esclavitud pero fue una de ellas
la decimocuarta enmienda fue llevada
adelante por el presidente republicano
para darle a los humanos negros sus
derechos ambos grupos fue fundado en
y refundado en 1915 con la presidencia
de lemona the good guys decidió la
película de concusión en la casa blanca
los linchamientos de las personas negras
los eeuu se producen se produjeron a los
estados del sur donde todos los
gobernadores eran demócratas y no pueden
ser todos todos durante muchísimos años
la sensible respecto de revalidad ésta
no tenía ninguna fuerza en las leyes de
segregación jim crow
de los cuarentas en el este no estado
jesús eso sí era simple institucional
sistema
porque habían instituciones y leyes para
impedir señor interrumpo para ir con el
discurso de cámara javi y vuelvo nozette
gracias y esto es un testimonio de la
dedicación de las generaciones antes de
hombres y mujeres que creyeron con
fuerza en la promesa de equidad libertad
y justicia para todos
esta semana se marcará aniversario
número 100 de la aprobación de la
enmienda número 19 y celebramos a las
mujeres que pelearon por esa dirección
venir muchas de las mujeres que ayudaron
a esa victoria aún así se les prohibió
seguir votando pero estaban determinadas
sin reconocimientos organizar
organizaron y testificaron y marcharon y
pelear no sólo por su voto sí
si no por una silla en la mesa estas
mujeres y las generaciones que siguieron
trabajaron para hacer que la democracia
fuera una oportunidad real en la vida de
todas nosotras las que las pusieron el
camino para el liderazgo de personas
como para que mamá y hillary clinton y
estas mujeres inspiraron nos inspiraron
a tomar la antorcha y a luchar mujeres
como danilo gente y también a ser
constantemente marcando
hablamos mucho y muy frecuentemente de
sus historias pero como estadounidenses
y todos estamos sobre sus hombros
y hay otras mujeres cuyo nombre nadie
conoce y cuya historia no se comparte
otra mujer
en cuyos hombros estoy yo y esa es mi
madre
a los 19 años para perseguir su sueño de
curar el cáncer
en la universidad de california
reconoció a mi padre que estaría bien
llegó desde jamaica estudia economía se
enamoraron en la forma más
estadounidense posible marchando juntos
durante las marchas por los derechos
civiles y así que yo estuve caminando
viendo lo que la gente llama
problemas en mamá cuando me enfrenté a
la separación de los padres y mi madre
me crió y nos crió ella sola como muchas
de las madres corría todo el día
alrededor del río para darles el
desayuno ayudarnos y darnos comida y
llevarnos también a la iglesia
y lo hizo ver como algo fácil a pesar de
que no lo era madre de mi madre nos
insistió a mi hermana ya mi los valores
que llevamos siempre en nuestra vida nos
creó para ser mujeres orgullosas negras
y nos crió para estar orgullosos de
nuestra herencia envía y nos enseñó a
ponerte en la familia primero la familia
en la que naciste y la que elegiste es
más vender mi familia es mi esposo está
acá quien conociendo la cita a ciegas
que nos organizó mi mejor amiga nuestros
hermosos hijos que me llaman mamá y mi
hermana es mi familia es mi mejor amiga
mayor inass
mi familia son más tíos amarillas
la familia si según la madre que vivía a
dos casas y me ayudó a crecer la familia
esa hermandad
de la universidad mis hermanos y
hermanas la familia son los amigos a los
que recurro cuando mi madre es la
persona más importante de mi vida murió
por cáncer
e incluso cuando ella nos enseñó a
mantener en nuestra familia como el
centro del mundo ella también nos empujó
a ver un mundo más allá de nosotros
mismos ella nos enseñó a ser conscientes
y compasivas de las luchas de todas las
personas a creer sino que el servicio
público es una causa noble a pelear con
la justicia que es una vez
responsabilidad compartida esto me llevó
a mí a convertirme en abogada en fiscal
y en una senadora estadounidense y en
cada uno de los pases de ciudad a por
las palabras que he dicho desde la
primera vez que estuve en una corte
kamala harris pib para la gente
y peleado por los monos y los
sobrevivientes de abuso sexual contra
organizaciones criminales
transnacionales
he luchado contra los bancos y su
obtención de ganancias conozco un
predador cuando lo veo a mi madre me
enseñó si el servicio a los otros
le da a la vida significado y propósito
y como desearía que ella estuviera aquí
esta noche pero sé que me está mirando
desde arriba
sigo pensando en que una mujer de 25
años
que me dio la vida en california
en ese día ya probablemente nunca se
hubiera imaginado que yo iba a estar
aquí frente a ustedes ahora hablando
estas palabras
aceptó su nominación para la
vicepresidenta de los estados unidos de
américa
yo lo hago y me comprometo con los
valores que ella me enseñó con la
palabra que me enseñó a efe a caminar
por fe y no por lo que veo y con una
visión que fue pasada a través de
generaciones de esta opción
estadounidense es una que yo va a ir en
comparte una visión de nuestra nación
como una comunidad amada donde todos
somos bienvenidos sin importar cómo nos
veamos de donde vengamos
o a quien amamos y en el que puede que
no estemos de acuerdo en todos los
detalles pero en los que estamos unidos
estamos unidos por esta creencia
fundamental de que todos los seres
humanos tienen un valor infinito y
merecen compasión dignidad y respeto
un país donde vemos y nos cuidamos los
unos a los otros donde nos levantamos y
nos caemos como uno solo donde
enfrentamos nuestros retos y celebramos
nuestro
triunfos y que hacer juntos
ustedes hoy
este país se siente distante tan grande
el fracaso del liderazgo de donald trump
ha costado vidas y maneras de vivir
si ustedes son padres y están luchando
hoy con el aprendizaje a distancia de
los hijos están en una maestros en el
otro lado de esa pantalla
saben que lo que estamos haciendo ahora
no está funcionando
y somos una nación que está en luto y
está perdiendo vidas está lamentando la
pérdida de vidas de trabajos de
oportunidades son las normas y la
pérdida de la normalidad
de certeza y mientras este virus nos
afecta a todos tenemos que ser una
célula en iwo
no es una cosa que haya oportunidades
iguales para todos los negros los
latinos y los indígenas están sufriendo
desproporcionadamente y esto no es una
incidencia es el efecto del racismo esto
general de la inequidad de la falta de
educación o de la falta de cuidado de
salud de la seguridad de trabajo y el
transporte en la justicia en el cuidado
materno y reproductivos en el abuso
excesivo de la fuerza
nuestros policías
de la injusticia de nuestro sistema de
justicia este virus no tiene ojos
pero aún así sabe
exactamente cómo nos vemos los unos a
los otros y cómo nos tratamos los unos a
los otros
y seamos claros
para el racismo
tenemos que hacer el trabajo
por la vida de tantos otros que son
demasiados para nombrar por nuestros
niños y por todos nosotros
tenemos que hacer el trabajo para
eliminar y cumplir esta promesa de
justicia equitativa
bajo la ley porque aquí hay algo ninguno
de nosotros es libre
hasta que todos seamos libres
así que estamos en un punto de inflexión
entre el caos constante y la
incompetencia que nos hace tener miedo y
la inseguridad que nos hace sentir solos
es demasiado ya que hay algo que podemos
estar mejor y merecemos muchísimo más we
must
debemos elegir un presidente que traiga
algo diferente pero algo mejor en tu día
y que haga el trabajo importante
un presidente que nos una waylett y no
negros blancos latinos asiáticos
indígenas para lograr el futuro que
todos juntos queremos we must
debemos elegir a joe biden y les voy a
hacer algo que no conocía yo lo conocí
en la campaña
y conocí yo como el padre de mi hijo su
hijo y yo éramos fiscales de nuestros
estados de la web y california durante
la gran reflexión él y yo hablamos en el
teléfono casi todos mis días trabajamos
para ganar miles de millones de dólares
de los bancos que estaban cerrando y
tratando las casas de las personas y
hablábamos de su familia
como un padre solo iba en un tren de un
lado de willington a washington
hunter podían desayunar todas las
mañanas con padres se iban a dormir cada
noche
con el sonido de su voz leyendo
historias en word
mientras soportaron una pérdida
inexplicable estos chicos siempre
supieron que eran amados profundamente e
incondicionalmente y también me conmovió
esto de hecho el trabajo que hizo
mientras iba de un lado a otro
este es el líder que es la ley contra el
abuso a las mujeres de la vienen central
las mujeres que trajo a nuestro país de
la gran decisión en lo rescató
la ley de salud de obama
ya que que pasó décadas
promoviendo los estados en los intereses
de estados unidos a través del mundo y
yo
y estamos con nuestros aliados
y nos paramos contra nuestros
adversarios ahora tenemos un presidente
que convierte nuestras tragedias en
armas políticas
será un presidente que convierte a
nuestros retos en propósitos
joe nos va a unir a construir una
economía que no veía a nadie atrás donde
un buen trabajo que pague bien sea el
techo y santiso no el techo no nos va a
unir para terminar con esta pandemia y
asegurarse de que estemos preparados
para la próxima joe nos va a unir
para enfrentar y desmantelar la
injusticia racial mejorando el trabajo
de la generación yo y yo creemos
que nosotros podemos construir esta
comunidad llena de amor una que sea
fuerte y de central justa y amable y una
en la que todos
nos podamos ver a nosotros mismos
representados esa es la versión que
nuestros padres y abuelos lucharon es la
visión que hizo que mi vida fuera
posible y la visión que hace que la
promesa de eeuu con toda su complejidad
e imperfección faith sea una promesa que
vale la pena pelear así que no se
equivoque en el camino que hay por
delante no es fácil podemos caer nos
podemos tropezar
pero vivo los urjo a que cambiemos
ampliamente y vivíamos con nuestros
retos honestamente vamos a decir las
verdades y vamos a actuar con la misma
fe en ustedes
que les pedimos pongan en nosotros
nosotros creemos que nuestro país pues
todos nosotros vamos a levantarnos y a
luchar por un mejor futuro y ya no
estamos aciertos
lo vemos en los doctores los
trabajadores de la salud en el frente
que están arriesgando su vida por
personas que nunca me conocieron lo
hemos sabido los maestros en los
conductores en los granjeros en los
trabajadores del servicio postal en los
trabajadores en casa todos poniendo su
seguridad en riesgo para ayudarnos a
atravesar esta pandemia y lo vemos en
muchos de ustedes quiénes están
trabajando no sólo para que atravesemos
esta crisis
sino para hacer alguien dijo hay algo
que está pasando en todo nuestro país
no se trata de youth o de mí se trata de
ustedes
y es de se trata de nosotros
[Música]
gente de todos los colores de edades y
credos que están saliendo a las calles
pues waiting garcía y persuadiendo a sus
familiares a sus amigos organizándose
con sus vecinos y saliendo a votar
y hemos mostrado que cuando votamos
nos expandimos y expandimos el acceso a
la salud
en la centros de votación y nos
aseguramos que más familias trabajadoras
puedan ganarse la vida decentemente
y me inspira mucho la nueva generación
ustedes ustedes nos están empujando a
darnos cuenta y a realizar los ideales
de ver si una nación
no obstante nos están empujando a
trabajar por los valores en los que
creemos
la justicia la equidad y el amor yo
ustedes
cretz son patriotas que me recuerdan y
nos recuerdan que amar a nuestro país es
luchar por los ideales de nuestro país
en esta elección tenemos una oportunidad
de cambiar el curso de la historia
todos estamos en esta lucha y ustedes yo
y yo juntos
qué responsabilidad tan maravillosa
qué privilegio tan maravilloso país así
que vamos a pelear con convicciones
vamos a pelear con esperanza
vamos a pelear con confianza en nosotros
mismos y con compromiso con los otros es
merca con el eeuu que sabemos es posible
de américa eeuu que amamos
y dentro de unos años este momento va a
haber pasado y nuestros nuestros nietos
nos van a ver a los ojos y nos van a
preguntar
cuando había tanto en juego que se
sentía mi voz alta y les diremos
no sólo como nos sentíamos les diremos
la wii de lo que hicimos
gracias dios los bendiga
y dios bendiga a estados unidos de
américa
[Música]
kamala harris aceptó oficialmente su
nominación para esta elección
presidencial del 3 de noviembre y sería
entonces la fórmula vicepresidencial del
candidato joe biden para la elección del
13 de noviembre habló de la familia de
la mujer de la herencia habló sobre su
carrera como abogada también y como
fiscal por supuesto aceptó la nominación
habló de los valores la visión la
inclusión la dignidad del respeto y
también atacó un poco al presidente
donald trump dijo que fracasó como
mandatario que fracasó su administración
habló que la nación está de luto por la
cantidad de vidas perdidas por cuenta de
la pandemia de kobe de 19 de la pérdida
de la normalidad que se vive actualmente
por esta pandemia de coronavirus y dijo
nada también hablo por supuesto de él
afroamericano georges floyd que murió a
manos de un policía blanco hablo del
racismo estructural que se vive en eeuu
habló del abuso excesivo de la fuerza
haciendo referencia al caso de la pro
americano george void y por último dijo
una frase que con esa me voy a quedar
para darle paso entonces a nuestra
corresponsal en washington y luego a
nuestra corresponsal en nueva york antes
de ir nuevamente con nuestros analistas
y fue que cámaras árabes dijo que no hay
una vacuna para el racismo y es que
enfocó su discurso básicamente en este
racismo diana voy contigo para comentar
entonces un poco de lo que fue el
discurso de kamala harris también un
poco de lo que fue el discurso del ex
presidente barack obama y lo que vamos a
ver el día de mañana cuando ya se acaba
estos cuatro días de convención
demócrata en eeuu jana
así es lo que vemos con el discurso de
kamala harris es una continuidad en el
tema central del día de hoy que lo vimos
también en el discurso de obama y de
otros miembros del partido demócrata
mostrando como desde la perspectiva de
este partido
el presidente de donald trump ha
gobernado no para todos los ciudadanos
en los estados unidos sino para ciertos
sectores y por eso veíamos a hard day's
hablando sobre este racismo estructural
que ella dice el presidente pues ha
liderado en la nación pero también como
el fracaso del liderazgo que era el día
de ayer el tema central durante la
convención es el liderazgo ha costado
vidas ha costado trabajos a millones de
estadounidenses que enfrentan esta
pandemia pero también vale la pena
destacar que este discurso de hoy tuvo
un tema de inclusión social y eso era lo
que ella quería mostrar básicamente que
las minorías la minoría afroamericana a
la que ella representa la menor
e inmigrante porque ya es hija de
inmigrantes que también representa son
los que han sufrido más las
consecuencias de la exclusión durante la
administración del presidente de donald
trump y que se ha anotado ahora más
durante la pandemia porque son las
minorías las que no tenían acceso a la
salud porque el presidente de trump
estaba atacando obamacare las minorías
que se habían quedado muchos sin
subsidios federales porque sólo
aplicaban para aquellos que tenían un
estatus legal pero también vimos en este
discurso digamos ese carisma que le ha
inyectado kamala harris desde que fue
nombrada fórmula a la vicepresidencia de
bailén que le ha inyectado a la campaña
demócrata y que básicamente está
capitalizando un momento que está
viviendo eeuu un momento histórico donde
hay cientos de manifestaciones en contra
de esta discriminación buscando la
justicia racial que todavía se ven
la capital de los eeuu todavía en marcha
la mayoría de los sábados del movimiento
de black light matter así que ella logra
capitalizar todo esto en el discurso y
acepta oficialmente ya en la
vicepresidencia la candidatura a la
vicepresidencia del liderazgo de bailén
y lo que veremos el día de mañana será
ya este discurso el final de joe vaivén
aceptando oficialmente esta nominación a
la presidencia a la candidatura y donde
mostrará en su extenso discurso cuáles
serán sus propuestas si llega a la casa
blanca en el 2021 no sólo en materia de
recuperación económica debido a la
crisis que está viviendo eeuu sino
también en materia de inmigración en
materia de generación de empleo de salud
así que será un discurso extenso que
también contará con otras figuras
representativas del partido demócrata
así es diana gracias entonces por
acompañarnos en este especial le digo
hasta mañana cuando vamos a estar
también cubriendo el
de la convención demócrata y de
washington nos vamos hasta la ciudad de
nueva york con nuestra corresponsalía
mamá en sala
mamen entonces hablemos un poco también
de lo que estaba quiero retomar lo que
estaba diciendo diana que todavía se ven
las protestas de las personas
reivindicando sus derechos sobre todo el
movimiento black light manuel le
pregunto si en nueva york es lo mismo y
también retomar un poco el discurso de
kamala harris
si aquí las protestas también continúan
creo que es algo que en mayor o menor
medida lo estamos viendo en todo el país
como que al final washington jon nueva
york los ángeles sitios más grandes son
las que centralizan más atención de los
medios pero es algo que vemos en todo el
país y precisamente por eso
kamala harris ha hecho hincapié en el
tema de la raza algo porque por lo que
se le había criticado mucho en estos en
los debates de las primarias porque no
acababa de entrar del todo en esta
materia y hoy hemos visto que ha dejado
claro a lo que viene aquí es una
perfecta pareja política para este baile
con con bailén creo que la complementa
le complementa perfectamente y atrae a
esas masas que a las que piden pues
igual no llega tanto cómo son los
votantes femeninos los votantes más
jóvenes que ven en ella pues una
esperanza y una mujer que de alguna
manera va a hacer historia después de
que se cumplan 100 años más un día de
que la mujer puede votar en este país ha
sido muy interesante también el discurso
del ex presidente barack obama porque
por primera vez en estos tres días hemos
visto cuestiones concretas de por qué él
es el conjunto de baile en cámara harris
puede suponer una mejora de vida para la
gente común que al final son la mayoría
de los seguidores de los demócratas ha
sido muy interesante también el lugar
desde donde ha hecho este discurso ese
museo de la revolución americana en
ciudad del fiap para mostrar para dejar
claro lo importante que es no dejar
perder la democracia y algo que ha
llamado también la atención es el
hincapié que han hecho la mayoría de los
oradores de la noche de hoy en la
importancia de votar de no quedarse en
casa y llamar a ese voto a los latinos
para que este año puedan salir a las
urnas interesante también la empatía que
ha mostrado
barack obama con joe biden al mostrar
que bueno pues que yo bailé pudo
recomponer su familia y podría hacer lo
mismo con la situación en la que nos
encontramos ahora que no se encuentra
con un país fácil hay más de 40 millones
de desempleados y el producto interior
bruto anual cae casi un 33 por ciento
así que hay mucho trabajo que hacer y
esto y esto lo estamos viendo en estos
tres días de convención a todas las
grandes figuras han destacado durante
estas dos horas los temas más
importantes a nivel social y lo
interesante yo creo también ha sido que
lo han hecho con figuras con ciudadanos
no solamente con políticos interesante
también raúl que hemos visto comentarios
en la cuenta de twitter del presidente
de donald trump durante el discurso de
barack obama así que bueno ha estado
criticando lea en su línea habitual es
interesante que esté también un poco
siguiendo lo que está pasando en el
partido demócrata en estos días y eso
que trata de alguna manera de llamar la
atención de los medios de comunicación y
de alguna manera boicotear los eventos
que están teniendo lugar en dentro de
esta convención demócrata mañana va a
ser
un día desde luego súper emocionante un
colofón final a lo que hemos visto estos
días en el que vamos a escuchar pues
esto al posible futuro presidente que
nos va a contar un poquito pues cuál va
a ser la hoja de ruta para estos cuatro
años
mamen a usted también le digo hasta
mañana hasta las 20 horas bogotá quito
lima y quiero ir nuevamente en la ciudad
de washington la capital de eeuu con
michelle man at analista política
estratega demócrata y ex asesora del
departamento de estado de eeuu señora
maná quiero saber sus reacciones luego
de que ya vimos entonces todos los
discursos que esperábamos este tercer
día de convención demócrata y pues qué
podemos esperar ya sé a dónde van los
demócratas y si realmente que para eso
apuntan tienen chance de ganarle al
presidente de donald trump bueno yo
quiero subrayar las cosas que acabamos
de escuchar de él
la mujer que fue la primera decisión del
vicepresidente biden en su rumbo a su
candidatura final y su momento de ser él
el candidato de nuestro partido entonces
ella fue su primera decisión ok eso es
algo muy importante de entender la la
decisión de un señor quién es un líder
mundial es un servidor público es un
esposo es un papá y es un abuelo el
eligió a comala xerez una mujer de 55
años de california y hija de dos
inmigrantes y ella es africana americana
punto final
luego quiero subrayar que escuchamos
antes al ex presidente barack obama
donde hablo barack obama él habló en el
museo de la revolución no norteamericana
yo tengo el privilegio de haber conocido
el museo es un museo dentro del corazón
de la ciudad de filadelfia que es donde
creció la democracia norteamericana es
un simbolismo muy muy importante que
pasó en filadelfia escribieron y
afirmaron los documentos fundamentales
de nuestro querido país entonces nuestro
partido y nuestros líderes escogieron
lugares
obviamente centrales en la historia la
historia compartida de nuestro país de
lo que es eeuu
y entre los dos discursos escuchamos lo
que es necesario en este momento es
claro lo que dijo el presidente obama
que él entiende después de ocho años en
el despacho oval en la casa blanca él
entiende cómo son los retos de el líder
de eeuu para tanto para los ciudadanos
adentro del país como la gente por todo
el mundo yo como latina de corazón
entiendo muy bien lo que son los retos
en la relación de américa latina con
eeuu para mí y para muchísimos otros no
hay duda que la fórmula by dan harris
tiene lo que se necesita tienen el
entendimiento y el análisis necesario
para avanzar entonces como cerraron su
discurso cerraron su discurso en tocar
el corazón de todos los norteamericanos
en aprovechar y prepararse
para votar la votación es un derecho
fundamental es un derecho para que luchó
el señores y líderes y digo líderes de
dorados como el fallecido señor john
lewis y como el presidente john f
kennedy y para por antecedentes y
presentes como franklin roosevelt y el
renault los reds así que nos tocó y nos
nos pasó la palabra y él nos indica en
el camino como debemos defender los
derechos y meet the moment señor godó
voy con usted gracias señora amanat por
entonces su opinión y quiero ir con el
señor godo para ya ir cerrando este
especial de noticias para saber sus
apreciaciones luego de que vimos esta
tercera jornada de convención demócrata
en estados unidos y luego del discurso
por supuesto el plato principal de la
noche de kamala harris candidata a la
vicepresidencia del país
si rápido muchas gracias por la
invitación voy a tratar de resumir el
último auto mapache sobre todas las
intervenciones de bailén
obama y kamala harris
tuvieron mucho del tema racial
me había quedado en intervención
anterior que por la ley de derechos
civiles la leeré se subir le pueda
probar aquí en 1962 donde tuvo yo os
louis pero se aprobó con voto
republicano más de 100 votos en la
cámara de los 130 votos fueron
demócratas y en el senado fueron 29
votos en contra y 23 fueron demócratas
la inmensa mayoría de los gustos más es
al revés de 75 79 80 por ciento fue de
partido democracy no hubiera sido por el
partido republicano la ley de derechos
civiles no se hubiera pasado y lo que
pasó fue que después de eso todas estas
personas racistas demócrata jesús se
quedaron a ese congreso estaba en sonido
como si nada se habla de cambio de
partido esos falsos se quedaron
solamente hubo un transtorno aunque
cambio de partido se cambió a partido
republicano
en el franklin delano roosevelt hizo
elegir a dos jueces de la del ku klux
klan para la corte suprema de los
estados unidos de américa uno de ellos
de fuego black y estuvo 34 años como
juez de la corte suprema de los estados
unidos bien lo pertenecido a ku kux klan
nominado por franklin delano luz que
nunca quiso llevar a considerar una ley
anti linchamiento durante sus cuatro
pedidos porque es bueno saber que se
hizo cuatro del eje cuatro veces
presidente de los eeuu nunca tenemos la
ley entienden también de seguían echando
negros en el sur o sea es esta parte de
la hipocresía del partido demócrata me
gustaría que partido demócrata un día se
disculpara con la población negra de los
eeuu por todos los abusos que cometieron
con ellos sobre todos los linchamientos
de más de 3.000 personas documentadas y
los otros están defendiendo a los niños
yo no sé como un partido o una persona
se puede parar ahí a defender a los
niños cuando ellos defienden el hábito
cualquier persona que sea cristiana que
sea católica cómo va a pertenecer el
partido demócrata que están defendiendo
la voto en los buenos aire incluido cama
las artes y en el cubo ama incluye a
todos ellos sea como es posible eso con
qué mural se paran a decir que hay
muertos con corona vida cuando desde el
año 72 que se sede que legalizó a la 8
73 bueno hace muchos años ha habido más
de 60 millones de niños muertos al que
los estados unidos por un agosto y ese
partido sigue defendiendo a la última
tras ahora critican 130.000 momentos de
gol con abril 260 los que sean que no
deben ocurrir todas las vidas importante
pero no no no no no jueguen con ese con
esa retórica porque es no vacía que
unirnos estoy aparte en el recuento con
unas cosas que dijo cámaras rápidas creo
que hay que ser patriota de que hay que
unirse pero bueno inicia desde el lado
correcto porque la mayor cantidad de
muertos de víctimas en el mundo
pertenecen al socialismo y al izquierdo
y partido demócrata están en esa
dirección entonces no se puede ser
patriota y de esa manera pero si vamos a
unirnos vamos a dejar de ser demócratas
vamos a buscar lo mejor para el país con
un sentido común
apoyándonos en los hechos reales y en lo
que ocurrió la historia no se puede
borrar no la pueden borrar el racismo
partido demócrata hacia los ciudadanos
negros en los eeuu no lo pueden borrar
asuman lo enfrenten lo y tengan la
valentía de decirlo
con su con sus electores y así vamos a
llegar mejor a este país que dios los
bendiga tu señor godo entonces gracias
por sus opiniones gracias por supuesto
también por acompañarnos durante estas
dos horas y media de especial de ese
tercer día de la convención demócrata en
eeuu quiero agradecerle a ustedes tres
nuestros invitados el día de hoy era el
señor fernando gago analista político y
ex vocero en español de la campaña
presidencial de ted cruise en el estado
de la florida también quiero agradecer a
la señora michelle emanada analista
política estratega demócrata y ex
asesora del departamento de estado de
eeuu y por supuesto también al señor
patricio zamorano director de medios
hispanos del candidato presidencial del
partido verde
hawkins y analista internacional que
lamentablemente perdimos la comunicación
con él muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
por acompañarnos en este especial de
noticias también a nuestras
corresponsales y ustedes por supuesto
gracias siempre por estar en nuestro
canal por estar pegados a nuestra
programación que los espero mañana
también a las 8 de la noche ahora bogotá
quito lima para entonces darle
cubrimiento a este último el cuarto día
de la convención republicana en eeuu un
perdón la convención demócrata en eeuu
ya la semana que viene también hablando
de republicanos jamás está cubriendo la
convención republicana por supuesto yo
soy raúl blanco como siempre un placer
poder acompañarlos hasta una próxima
oportunidad que tenga usted una muy muy
buena noche
[Música]